- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of neurobiology
and ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, we are going to discuss the use
of deliberate cold exposure
for health and performance.
Temperature is a powerful
stimulus on our nervous system
and indeed on every organ
and system of our body
and cold in particular can be leveraged
to improve mental health,
physical health, and performance,
meaning for endurance
exercise, for recovering
from various forms of exercise,
for actually improving strength and power
and for enhancing mental capacity.
In order to properly leverage
deliberate cold exposure
for sake of mental health,
physical health and performance,
you have to understand how cold
impacts the brain and body.
So today we are going to discuss that.
We're going to talk about
some of the neural circuits
and pathways, some of
the hormones involved.
I promise to make it
all clear and accessible
regardless of whether or not
you have a scientific background or not.
We are also going to discuss
very specific protocols
that you can apply,
which leverage variables like temperature,
how cold, how to deliver
the cold, for instance,
whether or not you use a cold shower,
cold immersion, ice bath,
circulating water, or still water,
whether or not you're going
for walks outside in a t-shirt
when it's cold or whether or not
you're purposefully
using things like cryo,
if you have access to that or not.
One thing I can promise you
is that by the end of today's episode,
you will know a lot about the
biology of thermal regulation,
that is how your brain and
body regulates its temperature.
You will also have a lot
of tools in your arsenal
that you can use and leverage
toward improving mental health,
physical health, reducing
inflammation in the body,
improving athletic performance,
improving mental performance.
I promise to spell out all
those protocols in detail
as I go along and to summarize
them again at the end.
I'd like to make a point
now that I'm going to make
several additional times
during today's episode
and that is that temperature
is a very potent stimulus
for the brain and body.
That also means that it
carries certain hazards
if it's not done correctly.
Now, everyone shows up to the table,
meaning to protocols,
with a different
background of health status
and there's simply no way that I can know
what your health status is.
So anytime you are going
to take on a new protocol,
that means a behavioral protocol
or a nutritional protocol
or a supplementation protocol,
you should absolutely consult
a board certified physician
before initiating that protocol.
I don't just say this to protect us,
I also say this to protect you.
If you'd like to see
our medical disclaimer,
you can go to our show
notes, it's described there.
In fact, I encourage
you to please do that.
And in general,
when embarking on new
protocols in particular,
if they involve strong stimuli
like changing temperature
or placing yourself into
unusual temperatures,
I would encourage you
to progress gradually.
I would also encourage you to not look at
gradual progression as
the kind of weak version
of a protocol.
In fact, today I'm going to discuss
a really beautiful peer reviewed study
that involved having people
do deliberate cold exposure
so they were immersing
themselves into water
up to about their neck
and the water was actually not that cold.
It was only about 60 degrees Fahrenheit,
which for most people is pretty tolerable.
So nowhere near the kinds
of extreme temperatures
that one could use in other protocols.
And the interesting thing is despite
that fairly modest cold temperature,
by simply extending the duration of time
that people were in that water,
they experienced enormous
increases in neurochemicals
that ought to translate to
improvements in focus and mood.
And indeed, that's what's been observed
in subsequent studies.
So again, please see
our medical disclaimer
in our show notes, please
proceed with caution always,
please also understand that
the most potent stimulus
isn't always the one that you experience
as the most intense in the moment.
In fact, I would encourage you to you find
the minimum threshold of stimulus
that will allow you to
drive the maximum benefit
from each protocol and indeed,
I will point out what those
thresholds ought to be today.
I'll give you some simple formulas,
gauges or guides that you
can use in order to navigate
this extremely interesting and potent tool
that we call deliberate cold exposure.
Before we talk about
deliberate cold exposure
and its many powerful applications,
I'd like to highlight a study
that I find particularly interesting,
that I think you will find
particularly interesting and useful.
The title of this study
is brief aerobic exercise
immediately enhances
visual attentional control
and perceptual speed,
testing the mediated role
of feelings of energy.
Now, the reason I like
this study is first of all,
it's a fairly large size sample group.
They looked at 101 students.
These were college-aged students
and they had two groups.
One group did 15 minutes of
jogging at moderate intensity.
So they did measure percent
heart rates, et cetera,
but this would be analogous
to zone two cardio,
which I've discussed
on this podcast before.
Zone two cardio is cardiovascular exercise
that places you at a level where
you can hold a conversation
with a little bit of strain,
meaning that you can get the words out,
but every once in a while
you have to catch your breath
whereas if you were to push
any harder by any mechanism
going faster or on a
steeper incline, et cetera,
that you would have a hard time
carrying out a conversation.
So zone two cardio is a
common form of describing
that level of intensity that
they call moderate intensity.
So one group did 15 minute of
jogging at moderate intensity,
which I'm translating to
roughly zone two cardio.
The other group did 15 minutes
of relaxation concentration
that is somewhat akin to
mindfulness meditation.
And then they were analyzed
for perceptual speed,
visual attentional control,
something called working memory,
which is your ability
to keep certain batches
of information online.
Just imagine someone telling
you their phone number,
and you have to remember
that sequence of numbers
in your head for some period
of time, that's working memory.
And it depends very
heavily on the so-called
prefrontal cortical networks,
which are involved in planning and action.
And they also looked at
people's feelings of energy
and they measured that subjectively,
how energetic people felt.
Now the major takeaways from this study
that I'd like to emphasize are that
the 15 minutes of jogging group
experienced elevated levels of energy
for some period of time after
they ceased the exercise
whereas the group that
did mindfulness meditation
actually reported feeling more calm
and having less overall energy.
Now that's very subjective
and indeed they used
subjective measures to analyze energy,
but what gets interesting is
when they looked at performance
on these various cognitive
tasks and the two tasks
that they use were called
the trail making tests,
they have different versions of this,
version A, version B,
I don't want to go into too much detail,
but version A essentially
involves having a page of numbers
that are distributed somewhat randomly.
So one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight and so on,
but distributed randomly across the page
and people have to use visual search
to circle those numbers in sequence.
So this involves visual attention,
it involves some motor skills,
involves a number of things
that certainly require energy and focus.
The second test was the
trail making test part B,
as I mentioned earlier,
and this involved also
circling numbers in sequence,
but interspersed between
those numbers were letters.
So rather than just having
to circle off numbers in sequence,
they actually had to connect one,
then the letter A, then two,
then the letter B, et cetera
and remember these are randomly
distributed across the page.
The major takeaway from the
study is that the group that did
the 15 minutes of moderate
exercise prior to these two tests
showed significant decreases
in the amount of time required
to complete these tests accurately.
That is interesting and indeed
surprising at least to me,
because there have been many
studies looking at the effects
of mindfulness meditation
on the ability to focus.
The key variable in the study
turned out to be energy.
This subjectively measured
feeling I should say
of having more energy and
thereby the ability to focus,
especially in these high
cognitive demand tasks.
Now the takeaway from
this study for all of us
I think is pretty straightforward.
If you are going to sit
down to do some work
that requires focus and working memory
and cognitive attention
and especially if it's some
visual spatial control,
meaning you have to search
for things on a page,
you have to organize things on a page,
so some writing, arithmetic,
basically cognitive work of any kind,
15 minutes of moderate exercise done prior
to that work about could
be very beneficial for you.
This does not mean that
mindfulness meditation
would not be a benefit to you.
I wouldn't want you to conclude that,
but if you had to choose between doing
15 minutes of mindfulness meditation
and doing 15 minutes of moderate exercise
prior to a cognitive work about,
I would say the 15 minutes
of moderate exercise would be
more valuable at least based
on the data in this paper.
In many previous podcasts,
I have talked about the
powerful effects of doing things
like mindfulness meditation,
and other forms of NSDR,
non-sleep deep rest.
So these could be 20 minute
naps or just lying there quietly
with your eyes closed or yoga nidra
or NSDR scripts are available on YouTube
and various other places
free of cost of any kind.
You just go to YouTube, put in NSDR,
non-sleep deep rest.
Those protocols have been
shown to be very beneficial
for enhancing neuroplasticity,
the changes in the brain
and body that encode
or shift the neural circuits that allow
for memory to change,
that allow for learning to
occur after a learning about.
What I'm referring to today
in this particular study
is the use of moderate exercise
in order to increase
one's focus and attention
in order to trigger that neuroplasticity.
So the simple sequence here
is get energetic and alert,
do that prior to the learning about,
engage in the cognitive
work or learning about,
and then mindfulness meditation,
NSDR and so forth should follow.
And if you would like to access this paper
and like to look more at
the details in the paper,
we'll be sure to put a
link in the show notes.
The first author is Legrand.
And again, the title of this
paper is brief aerobic exercise
immediately enhances
visual potential control
and perceptual speed,
testing the mediating
role of feeling of energy.
And I also just want to
emphasize immediately.
I think most people out
there are interested in tools
and protocols that work the first time
and that work every time
and indeed, I think this
protocol fits that bill.
I'm pleased to announce
that I'm hosting two live events this May.
The first live event will be hosted
in Seattle, Washington on May 17th.
The second live event
will be hosted in Portland,
Oregon on May 18th,
both are part of a lecture series entitled
the Brain Body Contract during
which I will discuss science
and science-based tools for mental health,
physical health and performance.
And I should point out that
while some of the material
I'll cover will overlap with
information covered here
on the Huberman Lab Podcast
and on various social media posts,
most of the information I will
cover is going to be distinct
from information covered on
the podcast or elsewhere.
So once again, it's Seattle on May 17th,
Portland on May 18th.
You can access tickets by
going to hubermanlab.com/tour
and I hope to see you there.
Before we begin,
I'd like to emphasize that
this podcast is separate
from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford.
It is however part of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Athletic
Greens, also called AG One.
I started taking AG One way back in 2012
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking AG One
and the reason I still take AG One
once or twice a day is that it covers my
foundational vitamin
mineral and probiotic needs.
It also has adaptogens
and things like zinc
for immune system function,
but the probiotics are one
of the key features in there.
I've done several podcasts
on the gut microbiome,
which are these trillions of microbiota
that live in our digestive tract,
and that are crucial
for our immune system,
brain function and so on.
One way to enhance our gut microbiome
to ensure that it's
healthy is to make sure
that we get the correct
probiotics and Athletic Greens
has the correct prebiotics
and probiotics that ensure
a healthy gut microbiome.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They'll give you five free
travel packs that make it
very easy to mix up Athletic Greens
while you're on the road.
So in the car and on the plane.
I should mention the
Athletic Greens is delicious.
I love the way it tastes.
I mix mine with some water
and a little bit of lemon or lime juice.
The special offer is the
five free travel packs
plus a year supply of
vitamin D three, K two.
Vitamin D three has been
shown to be important
for a tremendous number
of biological functions.
Many of us who get sunlight
get enough vitamin D three,
many of us, even if we do get sunlight,
do not get enough vitamin D three.
So the year supply of vitamin
D three also has K two,
which is important for
cardiovascular function,
for calcium regulation.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel packs
and the year supply of
vitamin D three, K two.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality.
The company was founded by
two All-American swimmers
from Stanford and everything
about their eye glasses
and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind.
Now the glasses were initially designed
for athletic performance,
meaning they were designed
to be worn while cycling or running.
And indeed you can wear them
while cycling or running.
If you get sweaty, they
won't slip off your face.
They're very lightweight.
In fact, you hardly ever remember
that they're on your face,
at least I can't remember
that they're on my face.
I wear the sunglasses when I
drive, I wear readers at night,
but they're not just for
athletic performance.
They have a terrific aesthetic
so you could wear them to the office
or to work or to school, they look great.
Unlike a lot of high
performance sunglasses out there
that make people look like cyborgs,
these you would be happy to wear anywhere.
If you'd like to try ROKA glasses,
you can go to roka.com, that's roka.com
and enter the code
Huberman to save 20% off
your first order.
Again, that's ROKA, roka.com.
Enter the code Huberman at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Helix Sleep.
Helix Sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are uniquely designed
to your sleep needs.
Everybody knows the importance
of sleep for mental health,
physical health, and performance,
but probably what everyone doesn't realize
is that you have unique sleep needs,
your body and indeed the way you sleep
need to be matched the correct mattress
in order to get the best possible sleep.
Helix understands that and
if you go to their website,
they have a brief two minute
quiz that anyone can take
that will match your body
type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you.
So they ask questions like,
do you sleep on your side,
your back of your stomach,
or maybe you don't know.
Do you tend to run hot
or cold through the night
or maybe you don't know?
I matched to the dusk mattress, D-U-S-K,
because I wanted a mattress
that wasn't too firm nor too soft
and I've been sleeping on that
mattress for over a year now,
it's the best sleep I've ever had.
So if you're interested in
upgrading your mattress,
go to helixsleep.com/huberman,
take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress and
you'll get up to $200 off
any mattress order and two free pillows.
They have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try the mattress out
for a hundred nights risk free.
They'll even pick it up for
you if you don't like it
although I think you will like it.
I certainly love mine.
Again if you're interested,
go to helixsleep.com/huberman to get
up to $200 off your mattress
order and two free pillows.
Let's talk about the use of
cold for health and performance.
I confess I love this topic
because it takes me back
to my undergraduate years
when I worked in a laboratory
studying cold physiology,
its effects on the brain
and its effects the body.
And over the years,
I've always kept track of
the literature in this area
and indeed there have been
some tremendous discoveries,
both in animal models, so in
rodents like mice and rats,
but also in humans
and today we're going to
talk about both categories
of studies and I'll be careful
to point out when discoveries
were made in animal models
and when they were made in humans.
A key point when thinking about
the use of cold as a tool,
and the key point is that
you have a baseline level
of temperature that is varying,
changing across the 24 hour cycle.
So any use of deliberate cold exposure
is going to be super
imposed on that rhythm,
that circadian rhythm,
meaning that 24 hour rhythm.
The basic contour of your
circadian rhythm in temperature
is that approximately two hours
before the time you wake up
is your so-called temperature minimum.
So your temperature minimum is a time
within the 24 hour cycle
when your body temperature
is at its lowest.
So if you normally wake up around 6:00 AM,
your temperature minimum
is probably about 4:00 AM.
If you normally wake up at about 7:00 AM,
your temperature minimum
is probably about 5:00 AM.
It's not exactly two hours
before your wake up time,
it's approximately two hours
before your wake up time.
Now, as you go from
your temperature minimum
to the time in which
you're going to awake,
your temperature is rising slightly.
And then at the point where you wake up,
your temperature starts
to go up more sharply
and will continue to go up into the early
and sometimes even into
the late afternoon.
And then sometime in the
late afternoon and evening,
your temperature will start to decline.
And indeed, as you approach sleep,
your body temperature will drop
by anywhere from one to three degrees.
And in fact that decrease
in core body temperature
is important if not
essential for getting into
and staying in deep sleep.
So temperature rises with
waking, that's easy to remember.
It tends to continue to
rise throughout the day
and in the late afternoon and evening,
your temperature WILL start
to go down and the drop
in temperature actually
helps you access sleep.
That background or what we
call baseline circadian rhythm
in core body temperature
is important to remember
because it helps us frame both the effects
of deliberate cold
exposure and helps us frame
when you might want to use
deliberate cold exposure
in order to access specific states.
It also points to times
within the 24 hour cycle
when you might want to avoid
using deliberate cold exposure,
if your primary goal is to get to sleep.
So that's the circadian
rhythm in temperature.
Now I just briefly want to touch on
thermal regulation at the
level of body and the brain.
And this will be very
surprising to many of you.
Let's do what's called
a Gedanken experiment,
which is a thought experiment.
Let's say I send you
out into the desert heat
for a jog or a run and
it's very hot outside,
102 or 103 degrees, and you start to move,
you start to sweat
and of course your core
body temperature goes up.
Now, then I offer you a cold towel,
maybe a really, really cold towel
and this towel is saturated with water
so you could actually
squeeze the water out of that
and cool your body off.
And our Gedanken experiment
is for me to say okay,
where are you going to place the towel?
How are you going to cool yourself off?
And I'm guessing that
most of you would think
that the best way to cool yourself off
would be to drape that
towel over your head,
maybe your neck, over your torso,
that it would feel really, really good,
and it would cool you off.
Well, that's exactly the wrong approach
if you want to cool off.
And in fact, if you were
to use that approach,
your body temperature would
continue to increase even more.
Yes, even more than had you not placed
that cold towel on your
head or your torso.
And here is why.
Thermal regulation meaning
your brain and body's ability
to regulate your internal core temperature
is somewhat like a thermostat
and that thermostat
resides in your brain.
So if you think about the thermostat
in your home or apartment,
if it's too warm in your home or apartment
and you were to take a bag of ice
and to put it on that thermostat,
what would the thermostat do?
It would register the
environment as artificially cool.
It would think that the environment
was actually much colder than it is.
And so as a consequence,
it would trigger a mechanism
to further increase the
temperature in the room.
And you have such a thermostat as well.
It's called the medial preoptic
area of the hypothalamus.
The hypothalamus is a small
region of brain tissue
about over the roof of your mouth
and a little bit in front of that.
So it's basically right behind
your nose and over the roof
of your mouth and it's
a collection of neurons.
Those neurons have a lot
of different functions
that include things like
the control of aggression,
the control of sex behavior,
the control of temperature
regulation and so on.
The medial preoptic area
has connections with
the rest of the brain
or areas within the brain, I should say
and with many areas within the body,
it receives input from
receptors in our skin
and inside our body that
register temperature
and it acts as a thermostat.
So if the surface of
your body is made cool,
your medial preoptic
area will send signals
by way of hormones
and by way of chemicals that will serve
to heat your body up.
So what this means is that
if you want to cool down,
the last thing you want to
do is to bring a cold surface
of any kind, towel or splashing water,
to the majority of your body surface.
It might be very, very surprising to you.
And you might say, wait,
if I want to cool down,
I should jump into a cold lake
or something of that sort.
That's a different thing altogether.
What I'll tell you,
and we'll get into this
in more depth later,
is that if you really
want to cool down quickly and efficiently,
you should leverage particular portals,
meaning particular sites on your body
where heat can leave
your body more readily
and where cooling can have
a dramatic and fast impact
on your core body temperature,
can even save your life if
you're going hyperthermic.
We're going to talk more about
the specific protocols to reduce
core body temperature
for sake of performance
and avoiding hyperthermia
later in the episode.
Hyperthermia of course is a
very, very dangerous situation
because while your body can
drop in core temperature
somewhat and still be safe,
you can't really increase your
body temperature that much
before your brain starts to cook
and other organs start
to cook and by cook,
I mean the cells actually start to die.
So you have to be very, very
careful with the use of heat.
Heat stroke is no joke.
People die from heat stroke all the time.
You really want to avoid that.
One way to avoid that is to
cool the appropriate surfaces
of your body and the appropriate
surfaces in this case
are the upper cheeks
or I would say the upper half of the face,
the palms of your hands and
the bottoms of your feet.
I've talked about this
on the podcast before
and in the guest episode
with Dr. Craig Heller,
my colleague in the biology
department at Stanford,
but just very briefly, these surfaces,
the upper half of the face,
the palms of the hands and
the bottoms of the feet
are what we call
glabrous skin surfaces,
G-L-A-B-R-O-U-S, glabrous.
And those surfaces are unique
in that just below them,
the vasculature is different
than elsewhere in the body.
Normally the passage of blood goes from
arteries to capillaries to veins,
but just beneath the
glabrous skin on the bottoms
of the feet, the hands in
the upper half of the face,
you have what are called
arterio-venous anastomoses.
These are portals of
blood that go directly
from arteries to veins and in doing so,
allow the body to dump heat
more readily, more quickly.
So as it turns out that if
you are to cool the palms
of the hands, the bottoms of the feet
and the upper half of the face,
you can more efficiently
reduce core body temperature
for sake of offsetting hyperthermia
and for improving athletic performance
and maybe even cognitive performance.
So we will return to
the specific protocols
for doing that later in the episode,
I'll give you a lot of
details about how to do that,
how to do that without the use of
any fancy or expensive technology.
There are some technologies
that are now commercially
available, for instance,
the so-called CoolMitt
that will allow you to do
that with maximum efficiency,
but I'll also give you some
at home methods to do this
either in the gym or on runs
or for sake of cognitive work.
So the two key themes again
are understand that
baseline circadian rhythm
in temperature, and understand
that the best way to cool
the body is going to be
by making sure that
something cold contacts
the bottoms of your feet,
the palms of your hands and
the upper half of the face.
Ideally all three
if your goal is to lower core
body temperature quickly,
and again, just cooling
off the back of your neck
or the top of your head
or your torso with a towel
is going to be the least efficient way
to lower core body temperature
and might even increase
body temperature under certain conditions.
With those two points in mind,
we can start to think
about directed deliberate
cold exposure protocols,
and there are a number
of different reasons
to use deliberate cold exposure.
And I want to separate those out for you.
There are cold protocols
that have been tested
in peer reviewed studies that are designed
to improve mental performance.
They are designed to improve
things like resilience
or your grittiness,
or your ability to move through challenge
or to regulate your mind
and your internal state
under conditions of stress
and we can define stress
very specifically as times
when adrenaline also called epinephrine
and or norepinephrine
also called noradrenaline,
are elevated in your body.
Forgive me for the noradrenaline,
norepinephrine, adrenaline,
epinephrine nomenclature,
I didn't make that up.
It turns out that every once in a while,
scientists disagree, imagine that,
and you'll get multiple scientists
naming the same molecule different things.
So epinephrine and adrenaline
are the same thing.
I will use them interchangeably.
Norepinephrine and noradrenaline
are the same thing.
I will use those terms interchangeably.
Noradrenaline and adrenaline
are often co-released
in the brain and body.
So they work as kind of a pair to increase
our level of agitation,
our level of focus and our
desire and our ability to move.
They are often co-released
from different sites
in the brain and body with dopamine,
a molecule that is commonly misunderstood
as the molecule of pleasure,
but is actually the
molecule of motivation,
reward and pursuit.
So dopamine, norepinephrine
and noradrenaline
tend to be released together
under certain conditions
and today you'll learn how
deliberate cold exposure
can be used to cause increases
in the release of several,
if not, all of these in ways
that can improve your levels
of attention and your mood.
But the key point is that
your mental state is shifted
when you are exposed to
certain forms of cold,
and many people use
deliberate cold exposure
specifically to shift
their body state as a way
to train their mental state
so that they can better cope
with stress in real life and by real life,
I mean when life presents
stressful events,
and I will give you specific protocols
as to how you can do that, in other words,
how you can become more resilient
through the use of
deliberate cold exposure.
Now, because of the ways in
which deliberate cold exposure
can increase this category of chemicals
called the catecholamines,
that includes dopamine,
norepinephrine and epinephrine,
it can also be used to elevate mood
for long periods of time.
And I'm going to discuss
a specific protocol
that has been shown to
increase these chemicals
anywhere from 2.5X to
250%, to as high as 500%,
five times over baseline.
Now you might be asking whether
or not it is a good thing
to raise chemicals like
norepinephrine and dopamine
to such a great degree,
whether or not that's healthy for us,
whether or not they can harm us.
But it turns out that these
elevations in norepinephrine
and dopamine are very long lasting in ways
that people report
feeling vast improvements
in mood and vast improvements
in levels of cognitive
attention and energy.
So by my read of the literature,
these seem to be healthy
increases in our baseline levels
of these chemicals in ways
that can really support us
so I'll give you a protocol for that.
Now, those are some of the mental effects
of deliberate cold exposure,
but deliberate cold exposure
has also been studied
in animal models and in humans
in the context of increasing metabolism,
even in converting certain fat cells
that we call white fat cells,
which are the ones where energy is stored,
they're the ones that
we typically think of
as kind of blubbery fat,
to beige or brown fat,
which is thermogenic fat,
meaning that it can increase
core body temperature
and serves kind of the furnace
by which we increase our core metabolism.
So with a very broad stroke,
I can say that white fat is
generally the kind of fat
that people want less of
and beige fat and brown fat
is generally the kind of fat that
if you're going to have fat cells and
you certainly need fat
cells that you want more of.
They are thermogenic,
they help you stay lean.
They actually serve as a
reservoir for heating your body up
if you're ever confronted
with a cold challenge.
So we're going to talk
about how to use cold
for metabolism as well.
And of course,
people are using deliberate cold exposure
to reduce inflammation post exercise,
to reduce inflammation generally.
And people are also using
cold to enhance performance
in the context of strength training,
in the context of endurance training
and we'll talk about those data as well,
but where I'd like to start
is with mental performance
and I'd like to detail what happens
when we deliberately
expose ourselves to cold.
It's key to point out the word deliberate.
If I don't say otherwise,
then throughout this episode,
if I say cold exposure, I
mean deliberate cold exposure.
And the reason I point that
out is that as my colleague,
David Spiegel, and the
department of psychiatry
at Stanford says,
it's not just about the
state that we are in,
it's about the state that
we are in and whether or not
we had anything to with placing
ourselves into that state
and whether or not we did
that on purpose or not.
And what he really means
by that statement is that
there are important effects
of what we call mindset.
Mindset was a topic discussed
in the guest episode
with Ali Crumb some weeks ago.
If you haven't seen that
episode, I highly recommend it.
And the science of my mindset
tells us that if we are doing
something deliberately and we believe
that it's going to be good for us,
it actually can lead to a different set
of physiological effects than if something
is happening to us against our
will or without our control.
Now, this is different
than placebo effects.
Placebo effects are distinct
from mindset effects.
If you want to learn more
about that distinction,
please see the episode with Ali Crumb.
But again, when I talk about
cold exposure in this episode,
I'm talking about
deliberate cold exposure,
meaning that you are
placing yourself into a
cold environment on
purpose in order to extract
a particular set of benefits.
When we talk about deliberate
cold exposure, almost always,
that means getting uncomfortable.
And one of the most common questions I get
when discussing the use
of cold for sake of mental
or physical performance,
metabolism, et cetera,
is how cold should it be?
How cold should the water be?
How cold should the environment be?
And I just will tell you now
and I'm going to say this again and again
throughout the episode,
cause it will continue to be
true throughout the episode
and long after the episode is over,
how cold depends on your cold tolerance,
your core metabolism,
and a number of other features
that there is simply no way
I could know or have access to.
So I would like you to
use this rule of thumb.
If you are using deliberate cold exposure,
the environment that
you place yourself into
should place your mind
into a state of whoa,
I would really like to get
out of this environment,
but I can stay in safely.
Now that might seem a
little bit arbitrary,
but let's say you were
to get into a warm shower
and it would feel really, really nice
and you were to start
turning down the warm
and turning up the cold.
There would be some threshold at which
it would feel uncomfortable to you.
And if you were to continue
to make a little bit colder
than that, you would really
want to get out of the shower,
but you are confident
that you could stay in
without risking your health,
without risking a heart attack.
Now that's very different
than jumping into
a very, very cold lake or
I've seen these images of
people that will cut holes into
frozen over lakes and they'll
get into that cold water.
If you are trained to do that
and you have the right
conditions, et cetera,
that can be done reasonably safely,
but that's certainly not
what I would start with.
And for many people,
that would be too cold
and indeed some people
can go into cold shock
and can die as a consequence of getting
to that extremely cold water very quickly.
Now that's not to scare you away
from deliberate cold exposure.
It's just to say that there's
no simple prescriptive
of how cold to make environment
in order to extract maximum benefit
for mental or physical performance.
So the simple rule of thumb is going to be
place yourself into an environment
that is uncomfortably cold,
but that you can stay in safely.
And you'll have to experiment
a bit and that number,
meaning that temperature,
will vary from day to day.
It will vary across the 24 hour cycle
because of that endogenous,
meaning that internal rhythm,
in temperature that I
talked about earlier.
Low early in the day,
rises into the afternoon, drops at night.
You can actually do this
experiment if you like.
Try getting into a cold
shower at 11 o'clock at night
if you want versus try doing it
in the middle of the afternoon.
It's quite a different experience
and by quite a different experience,
I mean it requires quite a
different degree of resilience
and leaning into the practice.
Your willpower will have
to be higher I suspect
late in the day as it
compared to early in the day,
but that will vary of course
between individuals as well.
So the most common question I get
about deliberate cold exposure
is how cold should the water be?
And we've answered that with
uncomfortably cold to the point
where you want to get out,
but you can safely stay in.
The second most common question I get
about deliberate cold
exposure is whether or not
cold showers are as good,
better or worse than cold water immersion
up to the neck, for instance.
I also get a lot of questions
about whether or not
cryo chambers are better
than all the others,
et cetera, et cetera.
I'm going to make all of that
very simple for you by
saying cold water immersion
up to the neck with your
feet and hands submerged also
is going to be the most effective.
Second best would be cold shower.
Third best would be to go outside
with a minimum amount of
clothing, but of course,
clothing that is culturally appropriate
and that would allow you to
experience cold to the point
where you would almost want
to shiver or start shivering.
Now there are a number of different,
important constraints
that are going to dictate
whether or not you use
one form of cold exposure
or the other.
For instance, some
people don't have access
to cold water immersion.
They don't have access to ice
baths or cold water tanks,
cold ocean or cold lakes, et cetera.
In that case, showers would
be the next best solution.
I do want to emphasize that
there have been very few,
if any, studies of cold showers,
and you can imagine why
this would be the case.
In a laboratory,
you want to control for as
many variables as possible.
So placing people into a cold
water immersion or an ice bath
up to the neck and insisting
they keep their hands
and feet under is very easy to control.
It means that everyone can
do essentially the same thing
whereas with cold showers,
people are different sized bodies.
Some people are going
to put their head under.
Some people are going to lean forward.
Measuring the amount of cold
water exposure on the body
is very hard to do
and so there aren't a lot
of studies of cold showers,
but of course,
a lot of people don't have
access to cold water immersion
so they have to use cold showers.
And if you don't have
access to both, of course,
then going outside on a cold
day can be of a benefit.
But I will point out
that the heat transfer
from your body into water is much higher,
four times greater, if not even greater,
depending on the temperature of the water,
in water as opposed to in air.
So it's going to be much more efficient
to do cold water immersion
than anything else,
cold showers after that
and put yourself into
a cold environment would
be the third best thing.
I'm not going to get into cryo chambers
because they carry quite
a high degree of cost.
And again, there aren't
many studies of them.
So if you have access to cryo chambers,
I'm sure that the cryo chamber facility
has told you about all
these incredible benefits
and I don't doubt that some
of those benefits truly exist,
but most people just
don't have the resources
or the access to those
so we're going to leave cryo chambers
out of today's discussion.
And of course I realize
there's a fourth category
of cold exposure out there.
People are wearing ice vests.
Believe it or not, those
exist, ice underwear.
Yes, those exist.
You can look for them
on Amazon if you like.
They are putting cold
packs in their armpits
or in their groin or elsewhere in order to
stimulate some of the effects of cold
on mental and physical performance.
I'm not going to address those
in too much detail today.
They can be efficient in certain ways,
but as you'll learn about
later in the episode,
cooling the palms, the upper face
and the bottoms of the feet
is going to be far more efficient
and unfortunately I think most
of the people that are using
ice packs to increase
their core metabolism
are not aware of the glabrous skin cooling
and how it can be a very,
very potent stimulus
so we'll return to that later.
Unless I say otherwise,
I'm mainly going to be focusing
on cold water immersion
and cold showers.
So let's talk about protocols
for enhancing mental health
and performance using
deliberate cold exposure.
What happens when we get into
cold is that we experience
an increase in norepinephrine,
in noradrenaline release
and in adrenaline release.
The fact that cold
exposure, deliberate or no,
increases norepinephrine and epinephrine
in our brain and body means that it is
a very reliable stimulus for increasing
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
That's sort of an obvious statement,
but that obvious
statement can be leveraged
to systematically build up
what we call resilience.
Now, when we experience
a stressor in life,
whether or not it's something bad happens
in our relationship or something
bad happens in the world
and we feel stress,
that stress is the
consequence of increases
in norepinephrine and epinephrine
in our brain and body.
Very similar, if not identical,
to the kinds of increases
that come from deliberate cold exposure.
So deliberate cold
exposure is an opportunity
to deliberately stress our body and yet,
because it's deliberate
and because we can take certain steps,
which I'll describe in a moment,
we can learn to maintain mental clarity,
we can learn to maintain
calm while our body
is in a state of stress.
And that can be immensely useful
when encountering stressors
in other parts of life.
And that's what we call
resilience or grit,
our ability or mental toughness,
our ability to lean into
challenge or to tolerate challenge
while keeping our heads
straight, so to speak.
So one simple protocol
for increasing resilience
is to pick a temperature
that's uncomfortable
of shower or cold immersion,
and then to get in for a
certain duration of time
and then to get out.
Now, it's important to understand
that people will
experience different levels
of norepinephrine and adrenaline release
when getting into cold water.
Some people, because they
dread the cold so much,
will actually experience norepinephrine
and epinephrine increases
even before they get into the cold water
or under the cold shower.
Now you may have experienced this.
I've certainly experienced this.
I'm dreading it, I don't want to do it
and I have to force myself to do it.
And indeed epinephrine and
norepinephrine and its surges
can be thought of as sort of
walls that we have to confront
and go over.
And I'd like you to
conceptualize them that way,
because it allows us to build protocols
that can be very
objective and can allow us
to monitor our progress in
terms of building resilience.
So one option is to simply say, okay,
I'm going to force myself
to get into the cold
shower for one minute.
How cold, again, uncomfortably cold,
but you can stay in safely
or I'm going to get into
the ice bath for one minute.
Ice baths are very cold inevitably.
And what is also inevitable is that
when you get into the cold,
you will experience a surge
in epinephrine and norepinephrine.
That's non-negotiable
because it's mediated
by cold receptors on
the surface of your body
and your skin and the way
that they trigger the release
of norepinephrine and epinephrine,
not just from the adrenals,
from the adrenal glands
above your kidneys,
but also from regions of your brain,
like the locus coeruleus,
which cause increases in
the tension and alertness,
and from other locations in
your body where epinephrine
and norepinephrine are released.
In other words, cold is
a non-negotiable stimulus
for increasing epinephrine
and norepinephrine.
Even if you are the
toughest person in the world
and you love the cold,
that increase in epinephrine
and norepinephrine
is going to happen.
So the way to think about
norepinephrine and epinephrine
in this context of
building mental resilience
is that you have two options.
You can either try to
extend the duration of time
that you are in the
deliberate cold exposure.
So going from one minute to
75 seconds to two minutes
and so on over a period of days
or one way to approach this
and the way that I particularly favor
is to take the context of the day
and the moment into account,
meaning we have different
levels of grit and resilience
on different days and
depending on the landscape
of our life at the time,
even the time of day that
we're doing these protocols
and start to be able to sense
the release of epinephrine,
and norepinephrine in our
brain and body and see those
as walls that we want to climb over
in order to build resilience
and to start counting
the number of walls that we traverse
and the distance between those walls
as we do deliberate cold exposure.
Let me give you an example
of the timed protocol
because that one is very straightforward,
although I do not think it is as powerful
for building mental resilience.
The time protocol would be Monday,
I do one minute of
deliberate cold exposure
at a given temperature.
Wednesday, I extend
that by 50% and Friday,
I do deliberate cold
exposure for twice as long
as I did it on Monday.
And if I were to continue that every week,
Monday, Wednesday, Friday,
I would continue to either
increase the duration
or I would lower the temperature
and reduce the duration,
this kind of thing, very much
like sets and reps in the gym.
Now that option is very objective.
You could even log it in a book
and as you develop the ability
to stay in cold temperatures,
even progressively colder
and colder temperatures
for longer and longer periods of time,
you will become more resilient.
What do I mean by that?
Well, my operational
definition of resilience
is that you are able to resist
escape from the stressor,
the cold, by virtue of your willpower,
which is really your prefrontal cortex
causing top down control on your reflexes
and your limbic system
and your hypothalamus,
which are basically telling you
to get out of that cold water,
get out of that cold
environment and in doing so,
you are basically getting better
at controlling your behavior
when your brain and body
are flooded with
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
That's a very reductionist
way to explain resilience
or grit or mental toughness,
but it's a reductionist
way of explaining it
that is very closely
tied to the biology end
of the psychology.
And it is a fact that
norepinephrine and epinephrine
release in the brain and body
are the generic universal
code for stressor.
There is no unique chemical signature
for different forms of
stressors, that is the only one,
although of course there are
other chemicals involved as well.
So you could go for time and you could try
and reduce the temperature
and increase the time
over a period of days or weeks.
Now that's an attractive
way to approach things,
but the problem is that you
don't have an infinite amount
of room with which to lower temperature,
because eventually you
will get into temperatures
that are either so cold
that they are dangerous
or you have to stay in cold temperatures
for such long periods that
it becomes impractical
because presumably you also have to
take care of other aspects of your life,
you can't just sit all
day in the ice bath.
Now for that reason,
I favor a protocol in which
you build mental resilience
and mental toughness through
two different types of protocols.
The first one involves counting walls.
Now, what do I mean by walls?
I mean the sensation of, no,
I don't want to do this and
the idea or the sensation
in your brain and body that
you actually want to leave
that environment and go warm up.
Now again, for some people,
that will be even before
getting into the ice bath
or cold shower.
So if you are feeling very resistant
to getting into the ice bath
or cold shower and you manage to do that,
that's going over what
I would call one wall.
Then for some period of time,
you might actually feel
comfortable in the ice bath,
cold water or cold shower.
And you feel like you could stay there
for some period of time,
that you could stay there
for a minute or two minutes,
but inevitably, the next wall will arrive.
And I would encourage
you to pay attention to
when that next wall arrives
and actually having an awareness,
that so-called interceptive
awareness as we call it,
of when that next surge
adrenaline epinephrine comes
or whether or not it
reaches a certain threshold
in your brain and body that
you feel you want to get out
and you're able to stay in for
even just 10 seconds longer,
that means you've
traversed yet another wall.
And if you continue to stay
in that cold environment,
you'll find that the next wall will come
and the next wall will come.
Now eventually of course,
you will get very, very numb
depending on how cold it is
and you could also place
yourself into danger.
So you have to maintain cognitive control,
counting these walls,
traversing these walls,
but getting out at some point, of course.
So my favorite protocol for
building mental toughness
AKA grit, AKA resilience,
is to take into account that some days,
just getting into the ice bath
or cold shower represents a
wall, some days it doesn't.
Some days you get in and you
feel you could go 10 minutes,
other days you get in and you feel like
you could only go a minute and
setting a designated number
of walls before you start the protocol
is going to be very beneficial here.
So you say, as long as I can do it safely,
I'm going to do three walls today.
The first wall is getting in.
The second wall will
arrive when it arrives
and the third wall will
and I'll get over that
wall and then I'll get out.
The next day, you might do five walls.
The next day, you might
do three walls again,
but you might lower the temperature.
This gives you tremendous flexibility
and indeed it gives you much more latitude
to be able to use the same
temperatures in different ways,
or to reduce the temperature
only a little bit
and still get a lot of stimulus,
meaning a lot of results
out of a given protocol.
Whereas people who are just
going for temperature and time
eventually become cold adapted.
They get very, very good
at doing three minutes
or six minutes or even 10
minutes at a given temperature
and so then they feel like they have
to lower the temperature
even more and even more
and eventually they just bought them out.
There's nowhere else to go.
There's no way to get
improvements out of the protocol.
At least not in terms
of mental resilience.
Of course, there's still
the positive effects
on inflammation and metabolism, et cetera,
that we'll talk about in a little bit.
But the key thing here
is to design protocols
that are going to work for you over time
and for you very, very hardy,
very, very tough guys and gals out there
that can get right into
an ice bath or a very, very cold immersion
and you can just grind it
out for six or 10 minutes,
or you can even do that
by remaining peaceful,
well more points to you, but guess what?
That's the equivalent of
already having loaded up
the barbell with 600 pounds
and done your 10 reps.
There's not a whole
lot more variable space
with which to get benefits
from that stimulus.
And in the weight room,
people understand that you
can adjust, for instance,
the speed of the movement,
or you can start combining that movement
with pre-exhaustion, et cetera.
With cold exposure,
you don't have as much
variable space to play with.
So if your goal is to build resilience,
either go for time as a
function of temperature,
or what I suggest is to
start recognizing these walls
as an experience of resistance in you
and going over those walls,
set a certain number of walls
that you're going to go over
on a given day and do that
at a given temperature,
and then to mix it up.
And ideally you might even
throw in one more wall
at the end,
if you're really feeling bold and brave
because that's going to
build out further resilience.
But if you want cold
exposure to work for you
for sake of building up resilience
and mental toughness over time,
you're going to want to
vary this parameter space
in some sort of way.
And you don't have to be
super systematic about it.
That's the beauty of this kind of approach
because you're relying on the fact
that those walls really represent times
in which you are forcing
your top down control,
your prefrontal cortex to
clamp down on your reflex
and you're learning behavioral
control in the context
of your body having elevated levels
of these catecholamines,
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
And that translates to real life
in a much more realistic way I
believe because in real life,
you're not really engaging in stressors
for a given amount of time
that you know how long it's going to last
and you know the context, no.
Most stressors arrive
in the form of surprises
we don't like, text messages
that deliver bad news,
information about the
outside world or real world
and online interactions
that send our system
into a state of increased
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
And if you start to
think of those as walls
that you can tolerate and climb over
while staying and calm and clear of mind,
then you can really
imagine how the ice bath
and other forms of cold
exposure are really serving
to train you up for real life stressors.
The next question that I always get is
what should my mental state be
while I'm exposing myself
to this uncomfortable,
yet safe condition of cold?
Well, you have two options
and there are probably
other options as well.
One is to try and calm yourself
to remain as mentally still as possible.
The other is to lean into that challenge
and so to grind it out and here,
I have to say that this is
a lot like teaching someone
to drive on a gravel road.
For any of you that have
driven on a gravel road,
you know that there is no optimal speed
for all gravel roads.
It depends on the density
of the gravel, et cetera,
and the vehicle, et cetera.
So for instance, on some gravel roads,
when you start to drive and
the dust starts to kick up,
your best option is to drive fast
and put that dust cloud behind you.
On other gravel roads,
if you try and do that,
the dust actually kicks
up around the vehicle
and it makes it hard to see
and sometimes you have to slow down.
The same thing is true for getting through
deliberate cold exposure.
Sometimes it's easier to calm yourself.
One way to do that is
through double inhales
through the nose and extended
exhales through the mouth,
or simply by trying to
control your breathing
and reduce the pace of
your breath and increase
the volume of your breathing.
I have to say that everyone
experiences a shortening
of breath when they get into
uncomfortably cold water,
that is a universal
physiological response.
Everyone also experiences
a 30 to 80% decrease
in cognitive function, in
particular, the frontal cortex.
The metabolism of your
frontal cortex goes down,
the metabolism meaning the
activity of brain areas
associated with stress
and panic goes way up.
And so anchoring your mind
in cognitive activities
as you get into the cold can be very,
very helpful for
maintaining clarity of mind.
In fact, one thing that
I sometimes recommend
is that people try and engage
in some sort of cognitive
exercise while in the cold,
not as a form of distraction,
but as a way to maintain
clarity of thinking
and to learn how to do that
when the body is flooded
with all these chemicals
that make us stressed.
So for instance,
you could do math problems and
not two plus two equals four,
not three times three equals nine,
but things that require
a little bit more focus
and attention working memory and so forth.
You could also start to have thoughts
that you deliberately impose
a full sentence structure on.
That's actually quite tough.
You could try and recall
specific bouts of information
that are challenging.
This is teaching your
mind how to stay online,
or rather I should say,
this is you teaching
your prefrontal cortex,
how to stay engaged while you
have high levels of stress
in your body.
Years ago, I had a friend who works
in the neuroscience world,
research neuroscientist,
who was obsessed with
this very bizarre sport
that I don't necessarily recommend at all,
which is the combination
of boxing and chess.
You may have seen this on YouTube
where people will box around,
legitimate boxing around,
they're sparring all out often.
And then at the end of the round,
instead of resting in the corner,
they actually sit down and play chess,
and then they go back to
boxing and back to chess.
Again, not a sport that I recommend,
but the reason he was
obsessed with this is because
he studies the impact of stress
on cognitive performance.
And what that particular
very bizarre sport was doing
was toggling back and forth
between different states of mind.
Now it's used both to
increase cognitive clarity
for the fighter when they box,
because staying calm and clear thinking
is very important to
winning boxing matches.
Believe it or not, it's
not an all outrage.
It's a very calculated
game of mental chess
and physical chess
that's quite high stakes
as you can imagine.
It's also used in some circles
as a way to teach people
how to engage in cognitive performance
when their body is simply
filled to a stress.
So in the boxing chess example,
the replacement for the cold
water is actually the boxing,
it's the thing that's
supposed to induce the stress
cause getting hit is
stressful and the risk
of getting hit is
stressful for most people.
So again, if you think about
deliberate cold exposure
as a way of just
systematically and reliably
inducing epinephrine and
norepinephrine release
and delivering stress,
well then this idea of
maintaining cognitive clarity
and actually engaging in cognitive tasks
while in the ice bath or cold shower
can actually be very beneficial.
Even though it might
sound a little bit silly,
you are really training up your ability
to keep your brain working
when the reflex is to shut
down the parts of your brain
that are involved in deliberate
planning and thinking.
Now another important aspect
of deliberate cold exposure
that I rarely if ever hear discussed,
but is vitally important is whether or not
you move around or not.
And here's the reason.
When you get into cold
water and you remain there
for some period of time,
your body is generating
heat and that heat generates
what's called a thermal layer
that surrounds your entire body.
So if you stay still,
you are actually warmer
than if you move around,
you can try this the next time
you're doing your
deliberate cold exposure.
If you're submerged up to the neck,
sit there for about 10, 30 seconds
and be very, very still of body.
In fact, this is the way
that most people start
to do deliberate cold exposure.
They give this very stoic look.
They don't blink, they look very peaceful.
Some of them even look tough
or they make a very even A, emotional face
and so it looks like they're really tough,
but they are so still
that believe it or not,
they're not providing
the most potent stimulus.
If they or you were to
move around in that water,
what would happen is you'd
break up the thermal layer
and that you actually
experience that as much colder.
So if you really want to
push the resilience aspect,
or for instance, if you want
to use a given temperature
that you're comfortable in,
but that you want to increase the stimulus
and you want to get some more benefit
for mental resilience training,
well then get into the cold water,
move your body around continuously,
but try and keep your mind still,
or even do some sort of cognitive task.
So as you're starting to realize,
there are a bunch of different variables
that you can play with while maintaining
the same temperature of
water and in doing so,
really keep you in the zone of what should
and absolutely has to be safe for you
without having to just
continually drop the temperature
from say 60 degrees to 55 to 40 to 33
because as I mentioned before,
eventually you're going to bottom out.
So if you're one of those
people that likes to look tough
or really relaxed while
you're in the ice bath
or cold water immersion,
just realize that you're
actually cheating yourself out
of part of the stimulus.
Keep those limbs moving and of course,
limbs under the water, feet and hands
is going to be a more potent stimulus
than hands and feet out for reasons
that should be obvious based
on what we talked about
in terms of glabrous skin cooling.
Keep those submerged, move your body,
maybe move your knees up
and down, pedal your feet
and trust me, it's going
to feel a lot colder
than were you to remain stone still.
Another very common question
is how often to do
deliberate cold exposure.
It's tough to make a
recommendation on that
based on any peer reviewed study
although there are a few in
humans that point to a threshold
of 11 minutes total per week.
So that's total throughout the week
divided into two or four sessions
of two or three minutes or so.
Now that 11 minute cutoff
is not a strict threshold
and is actually geared more
towards increases in metabolism,
we'll get into this a little
bit later in the episode,
but I think the 11 minute threshold,
meaning 11 minutes total
of deliberate cold exposure
per week is a pretty good number to use
if you need a number in
order to keep you consistent.
But as we talked about earlier,
some of you are going
to be in the ice bath
or cold immersion or cold
shower for one minute,
others of you will be
in there for 10 minutes,
depending on how frequent
and how high, if you will,
those walls of adrenaline are coming.
So for some of you,
getting into a cold shower
for three minutes total
for the whole week will
represent a tremendous
achievement in terms of
willpower and overcoming
the resistance to doing
that, overcoming those walls.
For others of you, three
minutes is nothing.
So what do I recommend,
I recommend that you get at
least 11 minutes total per week,
but at the point where
11 minutes total per week
is very easy for you,
where is no longer representing
a significant mental challenge,
meaning you're not experiencing
many of these walls,
you're excited to get into
the cold shower immersion,
you're going through it easily,
you're cruising basically.
Then I would say either
lower the temperature safely,
of course, extend the
duration safely, of course,
or increase the frequency
so that you're doing this
perhaps every day or
maybe five days a week
or three days a week.
I personally get tremendous benefit
from doing deliberate cold
exposure three times a week
and using the walls method
that I described earlier
as my gauge for how long to stay in
and typically that means that
I'm staying in for anywhere
from two minutes to
six minutes per session
and that averages out to about
11 to 15 minutes total per week.
So again, I do not think that
you need to be super strict
about these guidelines.
It's most important when
embracing a protocol A,
that you do it safely,
but secondarily that
you do it consistently.
So find what you can do consistently
and then vary the parameters
that will allow you to continue to do
deliberate cold exposure consistently,
regardless of whether or not
you have access to a shower
or cold immersion, et cetera.
So we've been talking about mental effects
and the use of deliberate cold exposure
for sake of building resilience,
which I do believe can
be tremendously powerful.
Look, it's no coincidence
that the screening
and the training for Navy Seals
involves a lot of exposure to cold water.
One could argue that it is deliberate
because they elect to go to buds,
but when they get into
the cold water at buds
is dictated by the
instructors and the reason
they use cold water
exposure as the stressor
is that it does offer considerable leeway
in terms of duration and temperature,
in terms of how you can
use it as a stressor
whereas things like heat don't
offer much variable space
as we say.
There isn't a lot of room
beyond which you start injuring
or even killing people by using heat.
So there are a lot of forms
of stressors out there,
but cold is one that we can titrate,
that we can adjust in
ways that can allow us
to continually build up and
or maintain mental toughness.
Now, deliberate cold exposure
also has many effects
on chemicals other than
norepinephrine and epinephrine,
most notably the neuromodulator dopamine,
which is involved in elevating our mood,
making us feel energized and
enhancing our ability to focus.
And that has a lot to do
with how dopamine engages us
in motivated states,
tends to narrow our
thinking in our behavior
into a particular trench
of goal-directed behavior.
If you want to learn more about dopamine,
you can learn a lot about dopamine
in our episode about dopamine,
it's at hubermanlab.com.
You can find it, it's a
two and a half hour plus
kind of deep dive into
all things dopamine,
focus, motivation, et cetera.
Deliberate cold exposure
has a very powerful effect
on the release of dopamine
in our brain and body.
And this is one of the main
reasons why people continue
to do deliberate cold exposure.
Basically it makes us feel good
and it continues to make us feel good
even after we get out
of the cold environment.
In fact, some people would say
they don't feel good in
the cold environment,
it's all stress for them,
but afterwards they feel great.
One of our previous
guests, Dr. Anna Lembke,
who's a medical doctor
at Stanford University
School of Medicine, she's
a close colleague of mine,
described the use dopamine
in her book, Dopamine Nation,
an incredible book about
addiction and dopamine
I should mention.
And the use of dopamine
elicited by cold water exposure
by one of her patients.
What I'm referring to is the
fact that one of her patients
helped themselves get
and stay sober off drugs
by using deliberate cold
exposure to increase dopamine.
So a healthier form of dopamine release
than they were engaged in
prior to getting sober.
Now, the basis for dopamine release
in response to cold exposure
is that the catecholamines,
norepinephrine,
epinephrine and dopamine
tend to be co-released
by the same sorts of stimuli,
but most stressors and
in particular things
that evoke stress or our
feelings of stress internally
that we don't like do
not increase dopamine.
They only increase
norepinephrine and epinephrine,
but deliberate cold exposure
seems to cause a dramatic
increase in dopamine.
And this has actually been substantiated
in a really beautiful study entitled
human physiological responses
to immersion into water
of different temperatures.
The first author is Sramek.
I'm almost certainly
pronouncing that poorly
and if not incorrectly, S-R-A-M-E-K.
This was published in the European Journal
of Applied Physiology in the year 2000,
really a beautiful
study, I love this study.
They took people and they
had them sit in chairs
underwater but their head was
out and so they were immersed
up to the neck in either of
three different temperatures.
32 degrees Celsius, which
is 89 degrees Fahrenheit,
20 degrees Celsius, which
is 68 degrees Fahrenheit,
or 14 degrees Celsius, which
is 57.2 degrees Fahrenheit.
So not super cold, but then what they did
is they measured people's core
body temperature throughout.
They measured their metabolism
and they looked at serum levels
of things like norepinephrine,
epinephrine, dopamine,
and cortisol, serum
meaning within the blood.
So a really nice and quite thorough study.
There were not a huge number
of subjects in the study,
but nonetheless, it was
a very thorough study
in terms of the number of
variables that they explored.
So I just want to briefly highlight
some of what they saw or what
they observed in this study.
First of all, all the
groups were in the water
of a given temperature for one hour,
which is much longer than most
of the deliberate cold exposure protocols
that anyone is using at home.
I mean, maybe you're taking
one hour long cold showers,
maybe you're getting into
the ice bath for an hour
although I don't recommend that.
I think you'd probably get
badly hypothermic or maybe
you're getting into a cold water immersion
for some period of time,
but I have a hard time imagining
that it would be an hour
and I don't suggest
that if it's very cold.
So this study focused on actually somewhat
moderately cool temperatures,
not what I think most
people would consider
very, very cold temperatures,
but extended the duration
for quite a while.
So again, 32 degree Celsius,
20 degree Celsius or 14 degree Celsius.
Here's what they observed.
The group that was immersed up to the neck
in 32 degrees Celsius, that
is 89 degrees Fahrenheit,
water did not experience
a shift in metabolism
nor a significant increase in dopamine,
norepinephrine or these
other catecholamines.
The group that was in 20 degree Celsius,
meaning 68 degree Fahrenheit,
water for an hour
experienced a 93% increase
in metabolic rate, which is remarkable
given that the water wasn't that cold
and yet an hour is a pretty
long time to be in there.
And again, it speaks
to the dramatic effect
of heat transfer that water
has, which I mentioned earlier,
as opposed to being out
in the air at 68 degrees,
it would certainly not cause that increase
in metabolic rate.
The group that was at 14 degrees Celsius,
meaning 57.2 degrees Fahrenheit,
water for an hour experienced
a 350% increase in metabolism.
So huge increases in metabolism.
Now the most interesting data to me,
at least in terms of mental effects
of deliberate cold exposure,
were that the plasma or serum
levels of norepinephrine
in the blood increased 530%.
These are huge increases in norepinephrine
so it suggests that this
is a stressful stimulus
at least neurochemically
speaking, stressful,
despite the fact that
it's not super super cold,
although 57.2 degrees Fahrenheit,
14 degrees Celsius it's
not a warm environment,
but it's not a ultra,
ultra cold environment,
but an hour is a very
long time to be in there.
The subjects also
experienced a 250% increase
in dopamine concentrations,
which while not 530% as
it was with norepinephrine
is still a very large increase
in baseline levels of dopamine.
And what was interesting is
that those increases in dopamine
persisted for a very long
period of time afterwards,
even out to two hours.
And they stopped the
study after 120 minutes
of getting out of the
cold, but nonetheless,
these increases in norepinephrine
are huge and long lasting
and these increases in dopamine
are very large and long lasting.
And I do believe that these
documented effects in humans
explain much of the enhancement
of attention and of feelings
of wellbeing and mood that
people typically experience
after doing deliberate cold exposure.
And the reason I say that is that
if you were to go back to the episode
that I did on dopamine,
or you were to go back to the episode
that I did with Dr. Anna Lembke
on addiction and dopamine,
what you would find is
that increases in dopamine
of the sort evoked by
deliberate cold exposure
are actually very similar
to the kinds of increases
in dopamine that are elicited
by things like nicotine
or from other behaviors
that are known to be
addictive and bad for us
because they lead to
other effects on the brain
and body that we simply don't want.
And yet deliberate cold
exposure provided is done safely
can create similar if not
greater increases in dopamine
that are not just fleeting,
that don't just occur during,
say the consumption of some
deleterious drug or activity,
but that are very long lasting
and that can be leveraged
toward activities other than
deliberate cold exposure.
So I want to emphasize this.
I'm not suggesting
that people do deliberate cold
exposure for an hour a day.
And unfortunately there
are not many studies yet
exploring how shorter colder temperature
environment exposure, say
one minute or three minutes
or six minutes at 55
degrees or at 50 degrees,
whether or not that leads to similar,
greater or reduced levels of
dopamine in the brain and body.
And yet almost everybody who
does deliberate cold exposure
will say yeah, it was stressful.
I didn't enjoy it, or I
eventually grew to like it,
but that I always feel better afterwards
and then that feeling last
a very long period of time.
And I think it's almost certain
that those experiences that people report
relate to these increases in dopamine
and in concert with the
increases in norepinephrine
also explain the other effect
that's commonly reported,
which is an enhancement in mental acuity
and the ability to focus.
Now, here we can extrapolate to the study
that I discussed at the
early part of the episode,
where I was talking about the use of
short 15 minute exercise,
kind of moderate intensity exercise
and how that was shown to
increase levels of energy
and mental acuity
in these working memory,
visual attention tasks.
And there, again, we
have to assume somewhat
because they weren't doing
neurochemical measurements,
but we can reasonably assume
that those improvements
in cognitive performance were due
at least in part to the
increase in catecholamines
known to a company, moderate
intensity zone two cardio.
So what you're starting
to see here is a theme.
The theme is that virtually any stimulus
that delivers more norepinephrine,
epinephrine and dopamine to our system
will sharpen our mental
acuity and elevate our mood
and will do so for some period of time.
Deliberate cold exposure, it turns out,
is a very potent way to
increase these catecholamines,
this category of chemicals
and thereby to improve mood,
mental acuity and levels of alertness.
And as we'll next see, it
not only has that effect,
which can be very
beneficial for many people
in a bunch of different circumstances,
but it also has the positive
effects that many people seek
in terms of metabolism, in
lowering inflammation in the body
and other physiological effects as well.
And forgive me,
I was almost ready to move on to effects
of deliberate cold exposure on metabolism
and inflammation and so forth,
but I neglected to point
out one of the other
very interesting aspects of the study
showing deliberate cold exposure
can increase in
norepinephrine and dopamine,
which is that they observed
no significant increases
in the stress hormone cortisol
and that is both surprising,
interesting, and important
because what it means is
that the quality of stress
that deliberate cold exposure
is creating in the body
is likely to be one of
what we call use stress.
Hans Selye, the great physiologist,
won a Nobel Prize for
distinguishing between distress,
which is stress in the brain and body
that causes the release
of things like cortisol
along with the other catecholamines,
and that we experience as
negative happening to us
and can lead to negative health outcomes.
And he distinguished that from eustress,
which was stress that we now understand
is associated with increases
in things like norepinephrine
and dopamine, but no
increases or minimal increases
in cortisol, and that can lead
to positive health outcomes.
So it appears that deliberate
cold exposure can create
what we call or what Hans
Selye called eustress.
In other words, it can create
a condition in the brain
and body in which we
are stressing ourselves,
we are training up resilience,
and yet we are creating
a neurochemical milieu
that actually has many health benefits.
Now I'd like to shift our attention
to the effects of deliberate
cold exposure on metabolism.
And I'd like to start by detailing a study
that was performed on humans
and published just at
the end of last year.
The title of the study is altered
brown fat thermoregulation,
and enhanced cold induced thermogenesis
in young, healthy winter swimming men.
And I should point out
that while the study
was only performed on male subjects,
there's no reason to
think that the effects
that they discovered
would only pertain to men.
I would hope that they would
also do a study on women
at some point in the future,
but the effects that they describe
are very basic core
physiological processes.
What they did is they looked
at at deliberate cold exposure
in this group of young men,
and they used that 11
minute threshold per week.
So in other words, they had
them get into cold water
for approximately 11 minutes per week.
And again, that's 11
minutes total per week.
They divided that into two sessions
although in speaking with the
first author of this study,
Dr. Susanna Søberg,
I learned that it
probably is not important
that it be two sessions,
it could be three or even four sessions,
as long as it reaches
that 11 minute threshold.
What they discovered was
that by going into
these cold environments,
in this case cold water
immersion up to the neck,
for 11 minutes total per week,
that these men experienced increases
in so-called brown fat thermogenesis,
I'll talk more about
what that is in a moment,
and increases in core body temperature
that translate to increases
in core body metabolism.
Now, the overall increases
in core body metabolism
that they experienced
were not extremely large.
They were statistically significant,
but they weren't extremely large.
However, the changes in brown fat stores
are perhaps what's most
interesting about this study
and I'll tell you why.
The metabolic increases of
deliberate cold exposure
are both acute meaning
happening in the short term.
When you get into the cold
and immediately after,
one does experience an
increase in core metabolism,
you burn some calories, in other words,
and while those might not be
very significant increases,
or I should say they can be
statistically significant,
but they are not enormously large numbers
of calories burned,
the longer lasting effects
of deliberate cold exposure
on metabolism seem to take
place by changes that occur
in the types of fat that
we store in our body
and the way that that fat
impacts our metabolism
at other times throughout
the 24 hour cycle.
This actually has a
somewhat anecdotal basis,
in particular in Scandinavia.
I don't speak Swedish nor I speak Danish,
nor do I speak Norwegian,
but I do have Danish relatives
and they were able to help me decipher
a common Swedish saying,
which essentially
translates to the fact that
in preparation for the summer, they say,
one should expose themselves
to warm environments
so that one is comfortable
in warm environments
in the summer.
That's one half of this
traditional Swedish
and also Danish saying.
The other half of this
traditional Danish-Swedish saying
is that in preparation for winter,
in order to not feel too
cold in cold environments,
one should prepare for those in the fall
by not wearing a jacket
and exposing one's self
to cold environments.
Now, of course, this is just
anecdotal cultural lore,
but it actually has a physiological basis,
which is by exposing
oneself to cold environments
on a repeated basis in
anticipation of exposure
to more extreme cold environments,
one can feel more comfortable
in those extreme cold environments.
And that's exactly what they observed
in this study by Søberg et al.
The men felt more
comfortable in extreme cold
if they had trained through
deliberate cold exposure,
which might not seem surprising at all,
but based on what we talked about earlier,
whereby deliberate cold
exposure evokes this discomfort
and this experience of
norepinephrine release,
at least in the short term,
then you would say, well,
shouldn't that deliberate
cold exposure also
make them feel uncomfortable
like they really want to get out?
Well, that is true
in the beginning of a deliberate
cold exposure protocol,
meaning in the first week
or in the second week
or the third week, but what one finds
and what you will find if you do
deliberate cold exposure
consistently is that you will then
become more comfortable
at cold temperatures
away from the deliberate cold exposure.
So whereas you might have
previously been the person
who is always cold in the
room with air conditioning,
or always seeking a sweater,
always wanting to bundle up,
you will be more comfortable
in those cold environments.
And the reason for that
is well substantiated
from this study and from animal studies
whereby deliberate cold exposure
converts one particular kind of fat cell,
the white fat cell,
which is a very low metabolic output cell.
It's basically a storage site for energy
in the body fat cells to a
different type of fat cell,
which is the beige fat cell called beige
because it's actually
beige or slightly brown
under the microscope, or
even to brown fat cells,
which are very dark under
the microscope and dark
because they contain mitochondria
and are very metabolically
and thermogenetically active.
In other words, white fat
doesn't burn many calories.
It's basically a storage site.
It's a bank account for energy.
It's filled with lipids,
and those lipids can be used
if the body needs energy
and if it goes into a caloric deficit.
Beige fat and brown fat
acts as sort of a furnace
or the sort of fat that
you would find in a kindle,
a fuel that can increase
core body temperature.
So beige fat and brown fat is very good
at raising our metabolism
and helps burn white fat.
Now of course,
it does that only in the
context of a caloric deficit,
but it can actually help
create that caloric deficit.
Having more beige fat and brown fat
can increase your overall core
metabolism, in other words,
the number of calories
that you burn per day,
and therefore the number of calories
that you need to either
maintain or to lose weight.
The simple translation of
this is that getting into
cold water for a total of
11 minutes, perhaps more,
but at least 11 minutes per week
divided into two or four sessions
can increase your core metabolism in part
by increasing your beige
and brown fat stores.
And we know how that works
at least in animal models
and there's now reason to suspect
that the exact same mechanisms
are occurring in humans.
The primary way in which
deliberate cold exposure converts
white fat cells into
these more metabolically
thermogenetically active
metabolism increasing
beige and brown fat cells
is because norepinephrine
released when we get into
the cold binds to receptors
on the surface of white
fat cells and activates
downstream pathways such as UCP1,
so this is an uncoupling protein one,
that acts on the mitochondrial
metabolism of cells
and increases the mitochondrial
output of those cells
and the mitochondrial
density of those cells.
In other words,
it takes a cell that has
a kind of a weak engine
or no engine for generating energy.
Although every cell has some mitochondria,
it takes cells that have
very few mitochondria
and increases the engine size.
It kind of stokes the furnace
of those particular cells
and actually can change gene
expression in those cells.
So that's what's really interesting.
Deliberate cold exposure causes
increases in norepinephrine.
which bind to receptors on the
surfaces of white fat cells,
which triggers the release
of things like UCP1.
It also causes the release
of things like P-part gamma,
and co-factor PGC1.
I'm going to refer you to a review
if you want to learn more about these.
For those of you that
don't want to learn more,
all you need to know is that
the downstream of all that
are increases in
mitochondria and metabolism
and actual genetic changes
in the white fat cells
that convert them into
beige and brown fat cells.
This is especially important for adults
because babies and young
children actually don't have
the ability to shiver
or they have a less
robust capacity to shiver.
Very small babies really can't shiver
so they have a lot of brown
fat in order to keep them warm.
Young children eventually
develop the ability to shiver
and maintain these brown fat stores,
mainly around the clavicles,
the heart, the upper spine,
and in the upper back.
And it's no coincidence that
kids can often run around
with a minimal of clothing
and be comfortable
in environments that
adults would be cold in.
As life goes on, we tend to
lose beige and brown fat,
but this mechanism that I'm referring to
points to the plasticity of white fat,
meaning the ability for
white fat to actually convert
its identity into this
metabolically thermogenetically
enhancing form of beige and brown fat.
So deliberate cold
exposure is a terrific way
to increase your core metabolism
and oftentimes critics will say, well,
the increase in metabolism
isn't that significant
although I do want to point out again,
the 93% and 350% increases in metabolism
from that previous study.
But critics then will say, well,
that doesn't really translate
to that big of a caloric burn
during the deliberate cold exposure.
But to that, you should say, ah,
but that's only limiting your optics
to just a portion of the effects
of deliberate cold exposure
because deliberate cold exposure
can also convert white fat
to beige fat and brown fat
and lead to these more lasting
increases in metabolism.
So for any of you interested
in increasing your metabolism
and or being comfortable
in cold environments
and or being comfortable in terms of
being able to combat stress mentally,
deliberate cold exposure, I
do believe is a powerful tool.
And there is simply no reason
why you couldn't and shouldn't
use the same protocols
that I described earlier
for building resilience
to increase metabolism.
Provided you're hitting that
11 minute per week threshold,
you ought to be stimulating
both mechanism increases
in resilience and increases
in core metabolism.
As I mentioned earlier,
most of the detailed studies
on the conversion of white fat
to beige fat and brown fat
through the use of cold
have been done in animal models,
but the human data are starting to emerge.
And if you'd like to do the
deep dive into these mechanisms,
things like UCP1, P-part gamma, et cetera,
there's a beautiful review
that was published recently
in the journal cell,
which is one of the three apex journals,
nature, science, cell.
And the title of that paper
is adipose tissue plasticity
in health and disease.
I love this review.
It has beautiful diagrams
detailing all of the pathways
from cold to norepinephrine through UCP1
downstream of things like cyclic AMP.
If none of those names
mean anything to you,
don't worry about it.
You certainly don't need
to know these mechanisms
to benefit from deliberate
cold exposure protocols.
If those names do mean something to you,
or you are interested in
exploring the downstream effects
of deliberate cold
exposure and something else
that's really nice that's
covered in this paper
is how deliberate cold exposure interacts
with fasted states and fed states.
I think you'll also find
this review very interesting.
I don't want to go too
deeply into fasted states
and fed states right now,
suffice to say that when we are fasted,
meaning when we have an eaten
for some period of time,
our baseline levels of norepinephrine
and epinephrine are already elevated.
And so cold exposure at those times
ought to have an even
greater effect on metabolism
and resilience and so on.
So for you fasters or your
intermittent fasters out there,
if you really want to get fancy,
you can do your deliberate cold exposure
when you are fasted.
I certainly wouldn't recommend doing it
with a very full stomach in any case.
And as I mentioned before on this podcast,
intermittent fasting is, but one way,
and certainly there are other ways
to limit total caloric intake
for sake of maintaining
or losing weight if that's your goal.
I know many people are using and benefit
from intermittent fasting, however,
and so it certainly can be combined
with deliberate cold exposures in order
to get even greater increases
in norepinephrine and epinephrine.
So for those of you that
are primarily interested
in using deliberate cold exposure
to increase dopamine levels
in your brain and body,
you can also do a combined protocol
whereby you ingest
caffeine 60 to 120 minutes
before the deliberate cold exposure.
This is based on a study
that I've talked about before
entitled caffeine increases
striatal dopamine D-2,
D-3 receptor availability
in the human brain.
And as the title suggests,
this study was done on humans,
looking at the density and or efficacy
of these dopamine receptors
in an area of the brain
called the striatum,
which is involved in planning in action
and also suppressing planning in action.
It's involved very closely
with whether or not
we can engage in behavior
and withhold behavior,
the so-called go and no
go ways in the brain.
Dopamine plays a critical role in that
and many other things
as well as you now know.
So why would you want to ingest
caffeine 60 to 120 minutes
before deliberate cold exposure?
Well, as I talked about earlier,
dopamine can increase quite substantially
in response to deliberate cold exposure,
but dopamine on its own
doesn't do anything,
it has to bind to receptors
and this paper shows quite definitively
that ingesting caffeine in this case,
it was 300 milligram dose of caffeine,
which is about the dose of caffeine
in two or three cups of coffee,
it depends on the strength
of the coffee, of course,
but it's not an outrageous
amount of caffeine,
that increases the density and or efficacy
of these receptors,
which you would allow that dopamine
to have its greatest effect.
And for those of you that want
to get really, really fancy,
I suppose you could do this fasted
so you get the further
increase in norepinephrine,
then you get the dopamine
increase from the cold exposure,
the binding of the dopamine.
Although I do want to point
out that at some point,
you start layering
together enough protocols
that you would to be
spending your entire day
trying to get this dopamine pulse
and I would hope that you
would have other activities
that you would engage in,
but if you're getting up in
the morning and you're fasted
because you haven't eaten all night
and you have a cup of coffee,
and then 60 minutes later,
you take your cold shower
or two hours later,
you do your cold immersion
or your cold shower,
you would be layering together
these different mechanisms
of dopamine receptors,
epinephrine and so forth in
a way that at least to me,
doesn't seem incompatible
with having some other life
like going to school and having
relationships, et cetera.
And this increase in dopamine,
particularly in the striatum
is not a trivial one.
I do want to point out as the authors do
that preclinical studies have shown
that increases in striatal dopamine
induced by things like modafinil,
which is used to treat
ADHD and treat narcolepsy,
is necessary for their
wake promoting actions.
What this really says is that
just having elevated levels
of dopamine from a drug
or from an ice bath,
or what have you is not sufficient
to get the effects of dopamine,
you really need the
receptors to be available
and you need those
in the appropriate density
receptors to be available
in the appropriate density in
the striatum in particular.
So I think there are a
number of reasons why
if it's compatible with the
other aspects of your health,
cause of course always
you have to consider this
on a background of cardiovascular health
and blood pressure, et cetera,
that ingesting a cup or two of coffee
an hour before your ice
bath may be fasted as well
could be quite beneficial
for increasing dopamine
over quite extended periods of time.
A couple of key points that
you'll want to pay attention to
in thinking about deliberate
cold exposure and metabolism.
In the Søberg study,
they also explored the use of
sauna and how to use sauna,
meaning deliberate heat
in conjunction with cold.
We are going to do an entire
episode about the use of heat
for health and performance.
So that is not the focus now, however,
it does raise an important point
that we do need to address at this moment,
which is if you are using sauna
or if you are taking warm showers
or if you are simply using
deliberate cold exposure
of any kind,
should you get into the heat afterward
or before or not at all?
And this is where we can
point to the so-called
Søberg principle, at least I
call it the Søberg principle,
the Søberg principle named after
first author of this study,
I referred to earlier, Dr. Susanna Søberg.
In science, it is appropriate
to take a key piece of data
and call it a principle
if in fact it translates
to something larger,
which I believe it does.
It is generally not appropriate for people
to name a principle after themselves
although there are a few
scientists that have done that.
So I have named it the Søberg principle,
but I did that to give
it appropriate credit
to Dr. Susanna Søberg,
who discovered that and pointed
out quite appropriately,
that to achieve the greatest
increases in metabolism
through deliberate cold exposure,
you want to force yourself
to reheat on your own
after the deliberate cold exposure,
meaning you wouldn't want
to go from the cold shower
to a hot shower or from
the cold shower to a sauna.
Rather if you were going
to start with a hot shower
or you're going to start with a sauna
that you would end with the cold,
and then you would reheat naturally.
Now I personally take a cold
shower a few times a week
or do cold immersion
and because I'm not specifically focused
on increasing metabolism,
although I probably should be,
that's not what I'm using it for now,
I will take a hot shower
afterwards and in doing so,
I'm short circuiting
some of the further metabolic
increases that I would achieve
were I to just end with the cold.
So the Søberg principle is
if you want to increase your
metabolism, end with cold,
and we can take this
a step further and say
that if you want to use
deliberate cold exposure
to increase metabolism,
that you should make sure
that you get to the
point where you shiver.
And the reason in for
this is that there are
a series of studies, but in particular,
one study published in the journal Nature,
excellent journal in the year 2018,
showing that deliberate cold
exposure that evokes shivering
from the muscles causes
the release of a molecule
called succinate from the muscles
and that succinate plays
a key role in activating
brown fat thermogenesis,
which you now have heard
about and understand
as critical to the increases in metabolism
caused by deliberate cold exposure.
So what this means is if you want to
increase your metabolism, end on cold,
that's a Søberg principle
and as best you can,
try and get to the point
where you are shivering
either when you are in the cold exposure
or immediately afterwards.
Now one efficient way to do
this is to, for instance,
you could get into the
cold shower for a minute
or two minutes or three
minutes, uncomfortably cold,
but safe to stay in.
Remember that's our general rule of thumb.
Then turn off the water and stand there,
make sure that you're not holding yourself
close to your body,
you're not hugging yourself
to try and keep yourself warm,
but rather your limbs are
extended at your sides.
And then if that fails to induce shiver
than to turn on the cold water again,
and then turn it off again,
so alternating perhaps a
minute to three minutes
of cold exposure followed
by a minute to three minutes
of drying out in air
and going back into the
cold exposure, et cetera.
I can tell you this from experience,
this is a pretty brutal protocol.
If you have never tried
getting into an ice bath
or cold water immersion
or shower for one minute
and then getting out and
trying to stand there
with your arms extended in cool
or cold air for one minute,
and then getting back into the cold shower
or water immersion, you are
in for an experience because
even for those of you that
are pretty shiver resistant,
you'll find that it is much, much harder
to get out of that cold water
and stand there arms extended
and drying off by evaporation,
which further draws heat from the body
than it is to wrap yourself in a towel,
get in a warm shower or a sauna.
So there's certainly no
requirement to end on cold.
There's certainly no
requirement to induce shiver,
but if your primary goal
is to induce increases in metabolism,
both in the short term
and in the long term,
following the cold exposure,
well then you'll want to end on cold
and you'll want to find a way to shiver
provided that the level of cold
that you're exposing yourself to
is still safe for you overall.
So up until now,
I've been talking about
deliberate cold exposure
as a potent stimulus for the
release of norepinephrine
in the brain and body and indeed it is,
but the way I've been describing
it has been in the context
of circulating plasma
levels of norepinephrine,
meaning circulating within the blood.
What I haven't mentioned,
but is absolutely true is
that the fat cells themselves
actually receive input from neurons.
So there are neurons that
release norepinephrine
in response to cold,
directly into the fat.
So I want to give you this
picture of how the architecture
of all this works,
because I think it can help you navigate
and indeed build better deliberate
cold exposure protocols.
Your adrenal glands release
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
Your brain has sites within
it like the locus coeruleus
that release norepinephrine
and epinephrine,
but there are also neurons
within your skin that sense cold
and other neurons that can
directly release norepinephrine
into the fat stores and
cause those white fat cells
to convert to beige and brown fat.
And I think this particular
aspect of our physiology
is often overlooked in studies.
And when people say, oh,
well the increases in
metabolism aren't that great,
the circulating levels of norepinephrine,
those are very large, but
they're very transient and so on,
that fails to understand that neurons
that actually sense cold are
in a position to communicate
via other neurons
directly to the fat cells
and release norepinephrine
into those fat cells,
which as I pointed out earlier,
set off a huge set of immediate
and long term cascades of
even gene expression changes.
So the picture that I'd like
you to have in your mind
is that when you get into the cold, yes,
of course you experience
that as a experience of
I don't want to do this,
I'm going to overcome this,
I'm going to climb over these mental walls
that represent adrenaline
release in my brain and body,
but also that your fat
cells are receiving signals,
norepinephrine signals that
are changing those fat cells
and the way that they metabolize energy.
Now I'd like to shift
our attention to the use
of deliberate cold exposure
for sake of physical performance.
And there are a lot of opinions out there
about the use of deliberate cold,
whether or not it should
be done for instance,
before or after exercise,
whether or not if done immediately
after strength training
or hypertrophy training,
meaning training designed to grow muscles
or make them stronger,
whether or not it can inhibit that process
and so on and so forth.
I think today in looking
over the literature
and trying to bring forward the simplest
and most straightforward,
and yet scientifically grounded protocols,
we can set up some general
guidelines that will allow most,
if not, all of you to
still extract the benefits
of deliberate cold exposure
on physical performance
without getting too neurotic
about the exact timing,
but for sake of discussion
and because it's a prominent theme
in many online communities,
let's just start with
the big one out there,
meaning the question of whether
or not doing an ice bath
or doing deliberate cold
exposure or taking a cold shower
after strength slash hypertrophy training,
meaning training designed
to increase strength
and or I should say the size of muscles
will somehow short circuit
or diminish that process,
whether or not it will reduce or eliminate
those strength gains
and hypertrophy gains.
And the short answer that
I was able to arrive at
on the basis of a review
article that I'll talk about
in a moment and some
other studies as well,
is that if your main goal
is hypertrophy and strength,
it is probably best to
avoid cold water immersion
and ice bath immersion in the four hours
immediately following that strength
and or hypertrophy training.
Again, if your main goal
is to achieve hypertrophy
or strength or some combination of those,
probably best to avoid cold
water immersion up to the neck
or ice bath immersion up to the neck
immediately after strength
and hypertrophy training
and extending out to about
four hours after that training.
If you're really neurotic about this,
then perhaps you'd want to
move the cold water exposure
to a different day entirely,
but it all depends on how
neurotically attached you are
to getting every last bit
of strength and hypertrophy.
And if that's your goal, terrific,
well then probably moving
the cold exposure four hours
or more away from that training
is going to be necessary for you.
Now you'll notice I did
not talk about cold showers
and the reason I did not
talk about cold showers
is that there simply are
not very many studies
of deliberate cold exposure
through cold showers
for the reasons I talked about
at the beginning of the episode.
It's hard for me to imagine
that taking a brief cold shower
after a strength or
hypertrophy training session
would completely reverse or
short circuit the effects
of that strength and hypertrophy training.
But again, if you're neurotically attached
to getting every last bit
of strength and hypertrophy
out of your training
sessions, then by all means,
err on the side of caution
and wait four hours or more
to do your cold shower just
as you would wait four hours
or more to do your cold water immersion.
Now there are nice data
pointing to the fact
that doing cold water
immersion after a hard run,
so endurance training,
or even sprint and interval training
or after a weight workout
where your main focus
is on performance of those movements
or after a skill training workout
where your main focus on
performance of those movements,
that there's no reason to think that that
cold water immersion or
ice bath or cold shower
would inhibit the progress or the stimulus
that would lead to progress
that occurred during
that training session.
In other words, I don't see any reason
based on the literature to
avoid deliberate cold exposure
immediately after training,
again unless your goal is
hypertrophy and strength.
And in fact,
there's a very nice
review recently published
on deliberate cold exposure
and how it can impact
physical performance,
whether or not it's done before or after,
different types of training and so forth.
The paper is entitled impact
of cold water immersion
compared with passive recovery,
following a single about
of strenuous exercise
on athletic performance in
physically active participants,
a systematic review with
meta-analysis and meta regression.
So this is a meta-analysis of 52 studies
that looked at a tremendous
number of variables
and contexts, as you would
expect in a meta-analysis
of 52 studies.
I'm going to read you the
conclusions of the study
and I will provide a link.
We certainly don't have
the time to go through
all the details of the study.
I will highlight a few specific outcomes
that I found particularly interesting,
but here I am paraphrasing
their conclusions,
that cold water immersion, I
want to emphasize immersion,
not cold showers, but cold water immersion
they say was an effective recovery tool
after high intensity exercise.
They observed positive outcomes,
meaning improvements in certain variables,
for muscular power, muscular soreness,
meaning reduced muscular soreness,
increased muscular power,
perceived recovery after
24 hours of exercise.
However, there were
certain forms of exercise
that were not benefited
by cold water immersion,
such as eccentric exercise,
exercise focusing only
on the lowering component
or the so-called eccentric
component of resistance exercise.
They saw some very entry
dose response relationships
for things like endurance
training, meaning the longer
the cold exposure post-endurance training,
the more improvement in
endurance performance,
reductions in circulating creatine kinases
and things that relate to muscle damage
under certain conditions.
At some point in the future, by the way,
we'll do an entire episode on
creatine and creatine kinase,
which are important not
just for muscular function,
but also for brain function.
But the basic takeaway was
that cold water immersion
performed after high intensity exercise
was beneficial from a number
of different standpoints
and indicated that shorter duration,
cold exposure and lower temperatures
can improve the efficacy
of cold water exposure
if used after high intensity exercise.
There I'm directly pulling
from their conclusions.
So what this says is
that it's not just those
longer duration, 30, 45
minute and 60 minute protocols
of cold water immersion
that we discussed earlier,
but also shorter duration
of one minute, three minute,
five minute exposures
to lower temperatures.
Temperatures that would
make you psychologically
want to get out as soon
as you possibly can,
but again that you can safely stay in
done after training
really have been shown to
improve outcomes in terms
of reducing soreness
and improving training efficacy,
meaning your ability to get
back into training more quickly
and thereby deliver more training stimuli
to a given muscle or in your
endurance training protocol.
Translate to English,
what this means is that taking
a cold shower or getting into
an ice bath or some other
form of cold water immersion
within the immediate minutes
or even the immediate hours
following your training has
been shown to be beneficial.
I'm sure a number of you
have questions for instance,
how long should you be
in that cold exposure?
Is it the same as the 11 minute
threshold described earlier?
To be honest with you,
there are not enough
studies to really point
to the critical threshold for eliminating
or reducing delayed onset muscle soreness
or for getting maximal results from power
and endurance training,
but this study does make
a couple of key points
and here I will just paraphrase.
For instance, that cold water immersion
is more likely to positively influence
muscular power performance,
to reduce muscle soreness, to
reduce serum creatine kinase,
and to improve perceived recovery
after high intensity exercise,
as compared with passive recovery.
This can be translated to cold
water exposure after training
is beneficial and probably better
than passive recovery from
a number of standpoints.
In addition, they say that
dose response relationships
meaning the amount and the degree of cold
that people were exposed to
and how often they did that
in particular in lower
temperature cold immersion.
So these would be the sorts
of cold immersion protocols
that are one minute or two
minutes, three minutes,
maybe five minutes,
but that one couldn't stay in there longer
because it feels stressful
and one wants to get out.
Maybe more effective after
high intensity exercise
for removal of serum creatine kinase
as well that these shorter duration
cold water immersion approaches
may be more effective
after high intensity
endurance performance as well.
So all of this can be
translated to say that
unless your main goal is
hypertrophy and strength,
that cold exposure, ideally cold immersion
and cold water ice bath,
but if you don't have access to that,
then cold showers is likely
going to be beneficial
if done immediately
after or in the minutes
or hours after your training,
especially high intensity training.
One particularly nice thing
about this meta-analysis
is that it included some studies that
involve the use of cooling packs.
So again, vests that can
essentially ice packs
and indeed even cryotherapy
chambers and so on.
There's a nice table in the study
if you want to get really detailed and go
and look specifically at those studies,
I invite you to do that.
We'll put a link to this
study in the caption
for this episode, but all in all,
what this study shows is
that deliberate cold exposure
can be very useful for recovery
likely through reductions
in inflammation, in muscle
and connective tissue.
And while this study did
not look specifically
at the mechanisms of reduced inflammation
caused by deliberate cold exposure,
those mechanisms are somewhat known.
There are a number of studies
that have pointed to the fact
that deliberate cold and cold generally
can reduce inflammatory cytokines,
such as IL-6, interleukin six.
It can increase
anti-inflammatory cytokines
such as interleukin 10 and so on.
Without getting into all those details,
I think it's sufficient to say that
if you are somebody who experiences
a lot of delayed onset muscle soreness,
taking a cold shower after your training
or getting into a cold
immersion after your training,
even if it's a few hours
later ought to help.
And if you are doing
particularly intense training,
then you probably want
to ratchet up the number
of cold exposure sessions
that you're doing
even if those have to
be done on separate days
from your training,
because a lot of the
inflammatory effects of training,
endurance and strength
training are actually occurring
some hours away from
the training stimulus.
So it's not just that inflammation goes up
radically during training,
which it often can,
but that it can occur even in the days
and even weeks afterwards,
depending how intense
and how long duration
that training is.
So deliberate cold
exposure is very powerful
as an anti-inflammatory tool.
Now I'd like to emphasize
the topic that we touched on
at the beginning of the episode,
which are those glabrous skin surfaces,
the hands, the upper face,
and the bottoms of the
feet through which heat
is especially good at leaving the body.
And another way of putting
that is that one can cool
the body much more efficiently
through the glabrous skin surfaces.
Now, if you want to
understand all of the science
behind this and all of
the various applications,
I invite you to please
listen to the episode
that I did with Dr. Craig Heller, again,
in the biology department at Stanford.
For sake of this episode,
I'm just going to detail
a couple of findings
from his laboratory.
The first one, dealing with
exercise induced hyperthermia,
because I think this is very interesting
and it can even save lives
if you understand the way this works.
There's a particular paper
that focuses on this,
and we will put a link to this as well.
The title of this paper
is novel application
of chemical cold packs for treatment
of exercise induced hyperthermia,
a randomized control trial.
This is a pretty brutal study,
brutal for the subjects that is.
This study involved was having
subjects walk on a treadmill
at a pretty significant
incline and anywhere
from nine to 17% wearing a
substantial amount of clothing
that was not well ventilated
and the room was kept
to 40 degrees Celsius,
which is 104 degrees Fahrenheit.
This is definitely not
something to do at home.
This study was designed
to induce hyperthermia,
which as I mentioned earlier,
can be quite dangerous.
And they compared two types of cooling.
In the first form of cooling
that they call traditional cooling,
they had ice packs on their neck,
in their armpits and in their groin.
And in the other group,
there was the so-called
glabrous skin cooling.
So the palms, the soles of the feet,
which were actually so they
were cooling inside the boots
or inside of gloves and on
the upper portion of the face.
And the basic takeaway of this study
is that by cooling the glabrous skin,
the subjects were able
to sustain this walking
on these inclined
treadmills for much longer
than were the people who
received traditional cooling.
And also the return to
baseline temperature
was much faster in the
glabrous skin cooling group.
So how this translates to the real world
is that if ever you are hyperthermic
or someone else's hyperthermic,
one way to cool them
down quickly is to cool
these palmer glabrous,
soles of the feet glabrous
and upper portion of the face
glabrous portions of the body
using cool rags, using ice
packs or using any number
of different cold objects or temperatures.
One key thing, if you're going
to use glabrous skin cooling,
is that whatever you use
to cool those surfaces
cannot be so cold that it
causes vasoconstriction.
Because as I mentioned earlier,
the arterio-venous anastomoses
these portals of arteries
directly to veins
that exist only in these
glabrous skin surfaces,
the way that they're able to cool the body
and essentially pass cool into the body
although that's not
really what they're doing,
they're actually extracting
heat from the body
to be technical, they're
extracting heat from the body,
the only way they can do
that is if those veins
don't collapse and veins will collapse
if they are made very, very cold.
So if you want to use
glabrous skin cooling
to offset hyperthermia
or for the other forms of performance,
which we'll talk about in a moment,
you need to use a cool object or surface
that is not so cold that
it causes vasoconstriction.
And this can be a little
bit tough to dial in,
meaning it can be tough to
identify such an object.
And for that reason,
Dr. Heller and some of his
colleagues have developed
a commercial product called the CoolMitt.
You can actually go to
their website, coolmitt.com.
I don't have any financial or
other relationship to them.
I know they've been
developing this technology
for some period of time.
It involves a glove that
you put your hand into,
it circulates water of a given
temperature and it does so,
and does so at a tempera
or that is sure to not
cause vasoconstriction of the palm.
And you may be asking,
how can you just put
your hand into one glove
and have this work?
Well, that's how powerful these
glabrous skin surfaces are.
Even just by cooling one palm,
the core body temperature drops radically.
Now that's their commercial technology.
I know that some people out
there have started to experiment
with a home version of this,
which would be taking
a package for instance
of frozen blueberries
or some other cold drink
or cold metal object, and
actually bringing it into the gym
or out on a run.
There are even people
who are now developing
cooled psych bicycle
handles for long rides.
This might seem a little
kooky or crazy to you,
but as you'll soon hear in the study
I'm about to describe,
the increases in endurance
and in the volume of strength training
that people can conduct
if they appropriately cool
their body through these
glabrous skin portals
is actually quite significant.
So again, as it relates to hyperthermia,
if someone is overheating by all means,
try and get them out of that heat,
get them to stop exercising,
you can die from hyperthermia,
try and cool the bottoms of the feet,
the palms of their hands
and the upper portion of their face.
That does not mean it would be a bad idea
to put cold water on
the top of their head.
That probably would also help
and perhaps on their neck.
What is probably not going
to be a good idea is to do
the more standard thing of
draping someone in cold towels
on the surface of their
body because as I mentioned,
the beginning of the episode,
that thermostat in the hypothalamus,
the medial preoptic area
will typically react to that
by increasing core body
temperature further.
The effects of glabrous skin
cooling on physical performance
are truly remarkable
provided the glabrous skin
cooling is done correctly.
And I want to point out that
the main degree of effect
is on volume or the
ability to do more work.
And I want to point this out
because I think that many people,
certainly in the exercise
science community,
but even in the general public,
when they hear about some of these effects
that are measured in the laboratory,
they sort of look at those
effects a bit of scans
and they think, well, that's not possible.
Effects for instance,
that have been documented
showing doubling or tripling
of the number of dips
that one can do in a
relatively short amount of time
or doubling of the number
of pullups one can do
or 14% increases in strength
or even comparable degrees
in increase in weight training output
to people who are on
performance enhancing drugs,
et cetera, et cetera.
Part of the confusion is that the effects
of proper palmer cooling,
because it almost always
is done by palmer cooling
and less often in these experiments
by cooling of the bottoms of the feet
and the upper portion of the face,
but those effects tend to be
the ability to do more work
over time and just to illustrate
some of the major effects
that the Heller lab is seen
and they are document
entered in this manuscript
that I'll share with you in a moment.
The typical protocol is
to have people come in
and do some endurance training
so running on a treadmill
and to have a condition where
one group is actually doing palmer cooling
while they are on a bike or on a treadmill
and inevitably the outcome is
that they can do more work.
They can pedal further at a given speed,
or they can run longer at
a given speed than people
who are not doing palmer cooling
or who are receiving cooling by way of
cold compress to the back
of the neck or ice pack
to the armpits, et cetera.
So the effects of palmer
cooling are very clear
and very robust.
And in the context of endurance exercise
almost always allow
people to do more work,
to go longer with less perceived
effort and to quit later
so to speak.
In terms of strength training,
they've looked at the capacity
to perform sets of dips.
So one of the more famous examples of this
that Dr. Heller shares in the
episode that we did earlier,
and that you can find at
hubermanlab.com involves
someone coming in and doing
sets of dips, maybe 40 dips.
This person actually could do
40 dips on their first set,
then resting for a period
of two to three minutes
and then doing 35
and then resting for a period
of two or three minutes,
and then doing progressively
fewer and fewer and fewer
to the point where over a period of time,
they add up the total number
of dips that they can do
and then they have them come back
after a period of recovery,
so not immediately after,
but take a couple of days,
come back and do effectively
the same protocol,
but during their rest periods,
they're doing two minutes
of palmer cooling,
which essentially allows
heat to move out of the body,
lowering core body
temperature in other words.
And what they find is that
they see enormous increases
in the total number of
dips that people can do,
but that doesn't mean that the person goes
from being able to do 40 dips,
to being able to do 50 dips
or 60 dips on that first set,
what it means is they are able
to do 40 on the first set,
then 40 on the second,
then 38 on the third
and so on and so forth
so that the total duration
of the workout is extended
and yet they're doing much more work,
even though it takes more time.
So that's an important point
and I think a point that
perhaps wasn't as clear
or as clearly made by me
in the previous episodes
that discuss this topic.
For those of you that are interested
in exploring palmer cooling, first of all,
I recommend taking a brief
glance or even a deep dive
into this study,
which is entitled work volume
and strength training
responses to resistive exercise
improve with periodic heat
extraction from the palm.
In this study, they describe
big increases in anaerobic,
meaning strength training output,
things like improvement in dips,
improvement in bench press,
improvement in pull-ups, et
cetera, in human subjects.
And it's a really nice study and points
to some of the protocols
that you might be able
to adapt in your own setup.
For instance, over six
weeks of pull up training,
palm cooling in between sets
improved volume by 144%,
and this was in experienced subjects.
So that's interesting
because a lot of studies
of strength training and
improvements in hypertrophy
and strength are done in
inexperienced untrained athletes,
which changes the picture somewhat
compared to experienced athletes.
They found that strength,
meaning the one repetition maximum,
increased 22% over 10 weeks
in bench press training.
And they point to the
particularly strong effects
of using palmer cooling
when people reach plateaus
in endurance and strength training.
And there, I think it's
an important point.
I think that if you're going
to explore palmer cooling,
it's probably not the sort of
thing that you're going to do
in every run or in every about of cycling
or in every strength training session,
but that it might be used to
vastly increase your volume
or vastly increase your endurance
in a given session or a set of sessions
in order to push through plateaus.
A particularly interesting
point in light of that
is Dr. Heller has observed again and again
that palmer cooling reduces
delayed onset muscle soreness,
or it can eliminate it entirely.
And that's very interest because
it also points to the fact
that reducing core body
temperature may somehow be involved
in short circuiting
the normal mechanisms of
delayed onset muscle soreness.
And you might say, well,
how would temperature be involved
in delayed onset muscle soreness?
Well, I want to refer you
back to the meta-analysis
that we talked about earlier,
where the short duration,
very cold temperature exposure
after training did indeed
reduce delayed onset muscle soreness
in part through reduction,
excuse me, in creatine kinase.
So it's not inconceivable that temperature
and delayed onset muscle
soreness are related.
And that raises perhaps
the most important point,
which is the way that palmer
cooling can improve performance
by way of reducing core
body temperature is known
and that is because when
one engages in exercise
or muscular output of any kind,
strength or endurance exercise,
the range of temperatures under
which a muscle can perform
is actually very narrow.
There's an enzyme called pyruvate kinase,
which is critical to muscle contractions
and pyruvate kinase can only function
in a very narrow range of temperatures.
If that temperature gets too hot,
meaning if the muscle heats up locally,
whether or not by running
or cycling or swimming or weightlifting,
the ability for that muscle to continue
to contract is reduced and eventually
is short circuited completely.
And I think this is a much underexplored
or at least a much under discussed aspect
of so-called muscular
failure or the failure
of one to continue to endure in running.
So for instance,
when you run as compared to
a bench press or something,
you don't stop running
because you can't actually
contract the muscles further,
but somehow signals about the heating up
of muscular tissue are
conveyed to the brain.
There's a crosstalk there,
it's probably bidirectional
and people stop, they quit.
This is the quitting reflex.
In strength training, one can
no longer perform a repetition
or set of repetitions in part
because of heating up
of the muscle locally.
There are other mechanisms
as well, of course,
and I realize that,
but what's very clear from the
palmer cooling work is that
by simply holding onto a cool object,
remember not an object so cold
that it constricts the
vessels of the palms
or constricts the vessels
on the bottoms of the feet,
but by holding onto a
relatively cool object
in one or both hands in between
sets for two minutes or so,
you can very efficiently reduce
your core body temperature
and in doing so, reduce the
temperature of the muscles
that are doing the work,
increase the capacity for pyruvate kinase
to continue to allow
your muscles to contract
and thereby allow you to
do more volume of endurance
and strength training.
So a simple protocol that
Dr. Heller passed to me
is find a relatively cool object.
So you could, for instance,
fill two bottles with cold water,
maybe put a few ice cubes in there.
This is not exact because
we're not talking about
the commercial CoolMitt product here,
we're talking about an at home version
or use a pack of frozen
blueberries or broccoli
sort of pack of those
as what he described.
And then in between sets to put your hands
and ideally you'd put
the bottoms of your feet,
but that's not always
feasible in most gyms
where they won't let you take
off your shoes and so forth,
but to put the palms of your
hands on that cool surface
for a minute or two minutes between sets
and then returning to your sets of work.
Now, if you are heating up
through other mechanisms
like you're wearing a stocking cap
and you're in a very warm environment,
this might not have as potent effect
as if you were to do this cooling
in a more moderate environment,
wearing lighter clothing, et cetera.
So by all means warm
up to do your exercise,
lubricate your joints,
and get into a place where you're
not going to injure yourself,
doing whatever form of exercise you do.
But then if you'd like to
explore palmer cooling,
I know a number of people
who've written to me saying
they heard about palmer cooling
on the episode with Dr. Heller.
They've tried this and they
see quite excellent results.
It does take some discipline.
It's one thing to just
kind of hang out in the gym
and play on your phone in between sets.
It's another to do deliberate
cooling with your palms
or the bottom of your feet
or the upper portion of your face.
You might get some weird looks,
but of course you'll be the one
doing significantly more volume,
not experiencing delayed onset
muscle soreness and achieving
better endurance and strength gains
were you to do this properly.
Now as a final topic related to the use
of deliberate cold exposure
for improving health
and performance, I'd like
to touch on this theme
that exists online, on social media,
on YouTube and in various
fitness communities
of using deliberate cold
exposure to the groin,
in particular to the testicles,
in order to try and increase testosterone.
And while this might sound really kooky,
indeed this practice exists.
Indeed if you were to go onto Amazon,
there are actually ice pack underwear
that are being marketed for
sake of increasing testosterone.
Now, I am not aware of any
specific well-controlled studies
that show that this indeed works.
I can imagine based on what I
know about the nervous system,
testosterone and cold, et cetera,
that there are a couple of mechanisms
by which one might experience
increases in testosterone
as a consequence of
deliberate cold exposure.
First off, let me say
there is no reason why
you would have to apply these ice packs
in the way that I just described.
One could of course take a cold shower.
One could of course use cold
immersion of various kinds,
and you're still going
to get that exposure
of the groin and the testicles to cold.
Now I should point out
that people do report
at least anecdotally
increases in testosterone
as a consequence of this practice
and I have to imagine
that they are measuring
their serum testosterone,
that they're not just guessing
that their testosterone went up.
If you know of a study
exploring this directly,
please let me know, put in the
comment section on YouTube,
or even just email me.
We have a email that you can
find it, hubermanlab.com.
Please email me the reference.
I wasn't able to find a reference,
but I can imagine two
reasonably plausible mechanisms
by which deliberate cold
exposure to the groin,
in particular the testicles,
would increase testosterone.
The first is somewhat direct,
which is that anytime
you cool a body surface,
that if it's cold enough,
you're going to get vasoconstriction.
And then subsequently you're going to get
a rebound increase in vasodilation,
meaning you're going to constrict
the blood vessels in that area.
And then after the cold is removed,
there's going to be more
blood flow to that area.
And of course,
blood flow relates to organ health
and tissue health generally.
So perfusion of that region
and the gonads to be specific
with additional blood,
you could imagine in some
ways increasing testosterone,
that's reasonably plausible.
The other probably more likely mechanism
relates to the dopamine
increases caused by cold exposure
that we talked about earlier.
Again, anytime you have a
somewhat stressful stimulus,
but in particular with cold exposure,
it seems that the catecholamines,
norepinephrine, epinephrine
and dopamine all increase
and dopamine is known to be in the pathway
that can stimulate testosterone.
And so while there isn't
a direct relationship
between dopamine stimulating testosterone,
there is an interesting
pathway way whereby
dopamine increases can trigger increases
in things like luteinizing hormone,
which can trigger
increases in testosterone
as well as estrogen for that matter.
So I know that there are
a lot of people out there
that are interested in
the use of cold exposure
for increasing testosterone.
And some of those people
in communities are
indeed using cold exposure
directly on the gonads,
on the testees in order to do this.
I'm not certain that that
direct contact is necessary.
And in some cases it might
actually be quite dangerous
or you at least should be
careful in terms of tissues there
and avoiding damage.
But nonetheless, I think
that a dopamine impact
on testosterone is very likely
given the 250% increases
in dopamine that have been observed
with cold water immersion and
all of that points to the fact
that cold water immersion
very likely increases testosterone,
but as a downstream consequence
of the cold water immersion
effects on dopamine
and luteinizing hormone,
and again there's no reason
to think that the increases
in luteinizing hormone would
also increase estrogen.
Probably not to dangerous or levels
that one would want to avoid,
but I don't think that there's anything
particularly specific about cold
for inducing testosterone
and not other hormones.
I think it's very likely to increases
a number of different hormones.
I do hope that there will be
a systematic study on this
in the not too distant future.
I also hope to not be a subject
in the cooling of the gonads experiment.
Now I promise you the last
topic was the last topic,
but there's one other
really important point
that I think everyone should be aware of
if you're going to use
deliberate cold exposure.
And that brings us back
to the very first thing
that we discussed today,
along the lines of
deliberate cold exposure,
which is that your baseline temperature
is going to be lowest about
two hours before you wake up,
it's going to increase in the morning
and as you wake up
and increase throughout
the day and afternoon,
and then start to drop in the
evening and come down at night
as you head to sleep.
I also want you to remember
that if you are to cool
the external portion of your
body, in particular your torso,
the net effect of that is
going to be an increase
in body temperature.
So for many people, not
all, but for many people,
if you are going to do
deliberate cold exposure,
you are going to increase
your core body temperature
and that makes sense
if you think about how
deliberate cold exposure
can increase metabolism by
increasing thermogenesis.
What that all means is
that if you are doing
your deliberate cold
exposure early in the day,
you are going to get
yet a further increase
in core body temperature
that would be associated with wakefulness,
your ability to be alert that morning
or throughout the day and so on.
It also means that if you do
your deliberate cold exposure
very late in the evening, or at night,
so 6:00 PM, 7:00 PM, 9:00 PM and so on,
you are going to increase
your core body temperature
and if you recall,
a decrease in core body temperature
of one to three degrees
is not just beneficial,
but is necessary in order
to get into deep sleep
and remain in deep sleep.
So the takeaway from this
is deliberate cold exposure
done properly will increase
your core body temperature
and make you feel more alert.
So if you're doing it early in the day,
that's probably terrific
given that most of us want
to be alert during the day.
However, if you do it too late
in the day, evening or night,
it can disrupt sleep by way of disrupting
your core body temperature.
Now, the caveat to that is I myself
tend to do deliberate cold
exposure early in the day.
Maybe not first thing in the
morning, but mid morning,
maybe as late as three
or four in the afternoon
in some cases.
In the longer days of summer,
I might do it even later,
five or 6:00 PM and have
no trouble sleeping.
I have done deliberate cold
exposure very late at night,
10:00 PM, 11:00 PM and so on
as part of a 30 day challenge
of doing deliberate cold
exposure every day for 30 days
and I got sloppy with my timing
and then in order to not miss a day,
I would do it at 11 o'clock at night.
And I must say
I found that I could still
fall asleep very easily,
even doing deliberate cold
exposure very late at night.
However, on those particular
days, I was particularly busy
and so I was particularly
exhausted when I arrived
at the deliberate cold exposure
and I had no trouble falling asleep
after doing deliberate cold exposure,
and then taking a nice warm
shower and then going to sleep.
But I could imagine that
because of the increases
in core body temperature caused
by deliberate cold exposure,
that were one to do that
too late in the day,
evening or night that it could
indeed disrupt your sleep.
So my recommendation would be
for most people only do
deliberate cold exposure
if you are prepared to be
fairly alert for the next one
to four or maybe had been six hours
following that deliberate cold exposure.
So for today's episode,
as is the case with most episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
I covered a lot of material.
We talked about mechanisms
of catecholamines and stress
and pulsatile release of
epinephrine, metabolism,
mental effects, performance,
glabrous skin cooling
and on and on and on.
And while the goal of course
is to make sure that everyone
arrives at specific,
very clear mechanistic
and actionable protocols,
I do realize that it is an
immense amount of information.
And for that reason,
I've created a list of deliberate
cold exposure protocols
aimed at improving mental
toughness and resilience,
mood, performance, metabolism,
reducing inflammation,
and so on and so forth.
All of those have been
condensed into succinct form
and can be found at the Huberman Lab
Neural Network Newsletter.
This is a monthly or
semi-monthly newsletter
that we release
that includes takeaways from
the podcast and protocols.
You can access those
as protocols zero cost
by simply going to hubermanlab.com,
signing up for the neural
network newsletter.
It's very easy to do, you
just supply your email
and you will receive the newsletter.
We do not share your
email with anybody else.
In fact, we have our
privacy policy laid out
on the hubermanlab.com website
so you can find that
there and the protocols
that I've designed should
make it very straightforward
for you to create a set of protocols
that you could use with cold
showers, with cold immersion,
with or without ice in
combination with exercise
specifically for one goal or another,
or to accomplish multiple
goals simultaneously.
If you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe
to the podcast on Spotify
and or Apple and on Apple,
you have the opportunity to leave us
up to a five star review.
You can also now leave reviews on Spotify
so we'd appreciate if you would do so.
If you have suggestions
for future guests or topics
that you would like us to
cover or feedback generally
for the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please put that in the
comment section on YouTube.
Please also check out
the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's episode,
that is the best way to
support this podcast.
In addition, we have a Patreon,
it's patreon.com/andrewhuberman.
And there you can support
the podcast at any level
that you like.
On many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we talk about supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them,
for things like sleep and focus
and other aspects of
health and performance.
One issue with the supplement industry
that's very serious, however,
is that these supplement companies simply
do not use high quality ingredients
or the amounts of the ingredients
they list on the packaging
does not match what's actually
contained in their product.
For that reason,
we partner with Thorne, T-H-O-R-N-E,
because Thorne supplements
are known to be of the very
highest quality ingredients
and the very highest degree
of specificity in terms of
the amounts of the ingredients
that are listed on the packaging
accurately match what's
contained in their products.
If you'd like to see the
Thorne products that I take,
you can go to Thorne, that's
thorne.com/u/huberman.
And there, you can see the Thorne products
that I take and get 20%
off any of those products.
In addition, if you navigate
deeper into the Thorne site,
through that portal, Thorne,
thorne.com/u/huberman,
you can also get 20% off
any of the other products
that Thorne makes.
If you're not already
subscribed to Huberman Lab
on Instagram and Twitter, please do so.
There I cover science
and science related tools
that sometimes overlap with
the content of the podcast,
but oftentimes is distinct
from the information
covered on this podcast.
So thank you once again
for joining me in the
discussion about the use
of deliberate cold exposure
for health and performance
and last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.